standby
are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
it's it's like when you buy stocks or
bitcoin or crypto or anything with
somebody else's money that they lend you
and you get a margin call like [ __ ] how
do i pay this back it's not a good
situation a lot of people are going
through it anyways we are live okay so
episode 159 today's guest is the one and
only
brian callan
uh famous for man comedian movies the
moment he came in first thing i thought
about when i saw him i'm like freaking
i'm going back to hangover the scene at
the church i can't get that out of my
head
you [ __ ]
that's it
just to be clear it's not like he's just
quoting you because you're here he says
it here he says it all yeah let me tell
you you don't remember me
all the time bro we met at cavalia
which was this horse show yes these guys
can do everything on a horse men and
women on a horse and and i think you you
were like i see this this big handsome
guy i think with a beautiful woman at
the time and you're like hey man i know
you from somewhere and i was used to
getting that i think we talked about how
long ago
dude it's got to be 10 11 12 years ago
it literally yeah yeah my daughter was
very young so yeah it was a while ago
and i someone like you got to be kidding
me you know then
obviously uh um
we had brandon shaban which was great it
was great talking to brandon and he
loves you right brendan also who yeah
brendan he's used to it he's just a
brand what i say brandon brandon yeah
well that's your thing you know like
people do it all the time
brendan schaab you'll call him brandon i
call him brianne
brendan shaw brandon friendship
listen mr shop is that easier for you
let's do that like how you say peter
thiel how about the guy
considers you a very uh athletic
individuals
high school shout out to the shout out
all
right
we'll get it
where he talked he brought it up on he
says i told one of the guys yeah you
know he was talking about one of the
guys you know what it was but we're
still friends
i thought brendan was a great guest i
think he's funny it is what it is we
played dodgeball and he can't throw a
ball i said it i said it out loud i saw
it
well you were telling the story about
how he blew out a couple of hamstrings i
don't know if you want to throw that
sword well it's common it was on the
podcast you know i'm begging him to warm
up before he sprints 100 yards since he
hasn't done it in 10 years and
he kind of went now
to you
he give me that right in the face yeah
i'm good the whole hands in the face
because because the thing about getting
older you realize the laws of physics
the laws of the universe apply to you
when you're young and you're like well
you know i don't
i have this joke about the fact that
when you're young you actually do
believe you're one of god's favorites
right you do you're invincible tragedy
and loss it's so sad over there but i'm
just going to keep it
yeah
and that's why you do crazy things like
parkour because gravity you know but
nobody in their 40s picks up parkour
because you realize well
the god there is no there are no
favorites yeah you know and it's it's
it's but there are though there are a
few favorites you my friend
you're you're looking [ __ ] he's
half a serious biblical
are you 50 yet how old are you 55. what
have you learned about are you really
get out of here bad right no [ __ ] what
have you learned about strategic skin
good for you
stretching because brendan schaub did
55. take your lesson forward i i do i
people laugh but i actually do yoga
every day but
not long really yeah but
my philosophy is moderation and i think
uh what i'll do is if i'm gonna lift
weights
i'll do 20 minutes but it's intense i'll
do maybe 15 minutes of yoga not this
hour and a half stuff and i think
consistency and then just learning not
to learning how to eat not getting crazy
not turning into a religion let's enjoy
our life please and and just at the end
of the day moderation golden mean
people get too crazy i'm carnivore i'm
keto i i just i'm sorry it's it's too
much it's i don't subscribe to that well
i got caught last week i was i was with
the girl i was in the bathroom because i
know we're about to hook up i was i got
caught stretching in the back she was
like why are you counting in there i was
like i was like just shut just mind your
business like don't worry about it wait
you're stretching before 400 percent i
don't want to pull something during
you know i mean
you did a bit we went to his comedy show
about how like you oh yeah sex in your
20s there's a lot of different secrets
about 40s and i told i did a bit where
i'm like you know when you were younger
you could pick the girl up go on the
dresser and she would throw everything
off the dresser i go that's hot at 20.
at 40 your whole life is on that dresser
there's antiques if a girl does that i'm
like time out that's my humidifier
picture it's a picture of my mother what
are you telling you adam
you have your mind yeah what are you
doing it's my whole mother
you also don't care i mean after a while
it's like all right we've done all this
yeah a little connection and we'll move
on
i got 15 minutes how did the stretching
work out for you though it's dude i'm
not because you know i'm i'm 44 years
old it worked i'm just saying like when
i hook up now by the little side thing i
have water a banana i don't do vitamin c
patrick i swear to god when you're
getting your four you guys when you're
when you're in your 40s i don't care
like what do you do make fun of me i
don't care anymore if i was 20 i'd be
like what do you look now it's whatever
bro i'm stretching i have to the whole
yoga thing by the way that that visual
is a little concerning yeah i'm just
thinking okay let me do the couple
stretches i'm coming baby you ready
banana on the no no no the the
stretching the stretching as she walks
in i heard somebody say
they were talking about the red queen
phenomenon that idea that you know you
have to run as fast as you can just to
stay in place right and it's a term that
they use sometimes which comes from
alice in wonderland and uh
i think when you get to a certain age
that's exactly what happens you start to
accept part of what wisdom might be is
coming to terms with your own
limitations coming to terms with the
fact that no matter what you do you are
a limited creature and you are you are
no matter what you do you're probably
gonna you're not gonna look as good next
year you're not gonna be as strong next
year no matter what there just comes a
time when you've got to accept the
inevitable decline of the body but i
think with that comes um hidden gifts
hidden such as what acceptance uh
understanding wisdom um letting go of
those kinds of things that you probably
shouldn't have been holding on to in the
first place and and and making room
in your mind for
other
other efforts and other understandings
how much of that you think is wisdom how
much of that is the fact that your
testosterone level is just lower
you know
this is this becomes the question
between biology and spirituality right
like it's so funny as as your biology
yeah
you somehow you get so serious
exactly like
why am i putting god down
i'm afraid i'm gonna get to heaven and
god's gonna have my entire life on one
piece of paper like my dad did with my
report card by the way think about it if
they ran the testosterone you know
levels of people go to church what that
would look like like attendance wise
probably very low cracking data yeah
that's what i'm saying like it's like
great question dude if i find a church
with
high testosterone level attendees think
about that church oh my god i mean
they're sinning every other second
yeah that's the church you want to go to
hell yeah i want to be at that time you
could draw a correlation i guarantee to
antibiotics to things that took care of
syphilis and other things where sex
didn't cost you your life and and and
also even the pill and all these things
that kind of liberate back in the day
dude sex was a very risky enterprise you
could get some crazy disease you could
get pregnant and be banished from
society and that so i think you're right
i mean a lot of things that kind of like
god kind of died with antibiotics and
birth control
yeah very true
you want to go to the church of calallen
over yeah you wonder how much of this
stuff like how much of it changes
because
literally you're becoming wiser how much
of it changes because
you don't have another choice like to
let go of that
you know uh uh
midlife crisis when some go through it's
like man i'm not 32 anymore you know i'm
not 38 anymore i'm not you know whatever
that number may be for some people
uh uh you see it a lot
i think like i remember being 28 years
old i meet this guy he says uh
you know 28 is one the toughest age a
man will go through i said tell me why
28. he says because you're
close to 30 friends are married with
kids you're no longer close to 20.
you're about to hit that number if
you're not married you're going to be
worried if your career is not said you
have all these types of anxiety and you
may make some stupid mistakes at 28. and
then you turn 38 and you're wondering if
there's this thing when the number
switches every single time like you go
from 39 to 40 from 49 to 50. did you
ever have something like that with you
or you're like yeah this is just 40 it's
just 30 you're just 50. no my biggest
fear was um regret and i was afraid i
think one of the most important things
are two
of the most important decisions i think
you make in your life one is who you
choose to spend your life with right so
if you're gonna if you're gonna get
married or you're gonna
bring somebody in your life that's a
very that decision should be treated
with great gravity and and
and i think if in a lot of times you
don't get lucky with that it's a tough
it's a tough thing but um i think the
other thing is to know to learn at a
young age and be ruthless with yourself
where are you supposed to place your
energy and i knew that if i didn't
become a comic or an actor i was gonna i
was gonna become a small person who
didn't like himself how old were you
when you knew that
i
i was
20 i was probably 21.
well i went to college and i said i'm
gonna try to be an actor and then i i
talked myself out of it i did some
acting and i said oh well this is very
difficult and i don't know what this
means and there's no linear progression
right i've always liked linear stuff
like if you show me how to get a black
belt or you show me how to learn how to
play the guitar if you show me the way
i'm going to do it and i'll and i'll
figure out a way to get better at it
because it's linear you just go straight
straight put your head down and just go
yeah i've i've always kind of thrived in
routine and practice i don't have a
problem with that when you have
something like acting or stand up and
you know vinnie it's like there's no
path man you've got to just continue to
be you're in the business of what i call
original self-expression but for me i
knew that once i made the decision to
become an actor and a comic that i was
going to be okay because even if it
didn't work out i had the courage to go
for it and i think you die a little bit
when you you knew the answer i think you
always know the answer
you know it's like this expression it
takes five minutes to fall in love and
the rest is denial and then there's
another expression which is people get
divorced after 20 years over what they
knew about that person in the first 10
minutes wow i think it's a very
important thing to keep in mind because
you know that about yourself you know
people ask questions me questions as i
get older and stuff you know they want
the young men who want questions about
life mostly you know the answer man
usually i go take a second do you know
the answer to this question you're just
asking me for affirmation right and i
understand that we all do it because
it's scary it's very scary
to
to actually take a minute
and visualize your best self
you're the hero of your movie there's a
coward of your movie and there's a hero
of your movie and then there's the guy
who's just
kind of going through his life and when
the gunslinger comes to town he closes
the shutters because he's afraid we have
all of that in us man but to really look
at the best version of yourself the
version of yourself that you would
admire that you would go to a movie to
watch the version of yourself that does
the right thing no matter what that
tells the truth and aligns himself with
the highest
truth or good that he can imagine or she
can imagine very scary because it
requires it takes responsibility man it
it and i don't think anybody can get you
there you have to stand on your own two
feet
and
sometimes it takes a crisis to force you
there you know
um but i think it's worth i really think
it's worth meditating on i think that's
that's that's the that's the north star
all of us should be kind of reaching for
and and i don't mean
just money and status and power i don't
mean just that i don't think that's
enough i really don't
i i think
it's something else and i do think brian
it's and and off of what you were saying
lying to yourself because you once
you're true to you like you said like
when you ask that dude you know you know
you know what you're talking about you
know and i tell people this all the time
i'm not saying be a liar [ __ ] people
[ __ ] you know little white lies that
protect people's feelings don't lie to
you
why are you lying to yourself you know
you're being full of [ __ ] once you're
honest and you don't give a [ __ ] about
anybody's concerns or i mean it's not
easier said than done when you just
don't care you're just being honest then
you could you know live your life do you
know what i like about this podcast i
watch this podcast i don't watch very
very few things uh and one thing i
notice about you it's gonna sound really
weird but um you listen very intently
and and
i've i've heard you and i've i've
watched you listen i've watched you
interview pretty formidable people too
some mafia guys or just some very
successful people
what i what i
what i liked about you and i didn't know
you but what i liked about you was that
you are genuinely interested
you're curious that has nothing to do
with money it has nothing to do with
anything else it's you're a driven guy
and you're successful but
that's
kind of what i'm talking about you know
there's this
there's this i think it's important to
kind of reach beyond yourself
think about how much of our culture
reflects directly back to ourselves open
a magazine it's all about
nutrition uh exercise it's all about
your biology all right dude i got it
your hair i mean there are ways to do it
but
that's not necessarily the answer
there are things that part of this whole
process of talking and podcasting what's
great is that man it feeds your
curiosity it satiates your curiosity the
world is okay
so many too many things in life are a
dark room and sometimes you get a
flashlight and you can look around and
yeah right so what a point by the way so
you when you were coming up
and you're saying 21 you kind of knew
because then you know i'm trying to act
like i don't want to afford this kind of
weird and then you're like i'm going to
go give this a shot i was working i was
a banker i was at lehman brothers get
out of here wow yes 21 33 right out of
college i was a history major i [ __ ]
my way into the accounts receivable
payables department
and i just dude i was there for 16
months and i was like i i i just don't
care about mortgage-backed securities i
was taking a class on that i kept i got
good rem sleep in that class good guys
i just wasn't my thing bro if you cared
a little bit more about it you could
have prevented a 2008 meltdown maybe
it's more convenient
guys bring them in if i looked at the
tranches
were you their late 80s early 90s was i
was there in uh yeah i was there i
graduated 89 i was there 89 90 91 wow
yeah yeah what a time to be playing
paddles right it wasn't i
attempted uh goldman sachs for almost
two years and uh this is where were you
i was in new york city in new york oh
yeah so i i just i mean i worked a
couple blocks away from the world trade
center so so so you know uh goldman
sachs was where i saw back then dude
that the quality of people they'd get
you come in i would see the resumes
you'd come in you'd be like a delta
force guy set yourself through harvard
and you had you could play the cello
well you know and you spoke 20 languages
and they'd be like you know what nah wow
it was unbelievable the quality how did
you get in i was a i was an actor
i was an actor writing bad plays doing
stand-up doing whatever i could was it
your personality that sold it or no like
was it a res because it's not the resume
right it's the personality did they meet
you they're like we like this guy yeah i
can fi i find more i make yeah i figured
yeah i get him laughing yeah who doesn't
want to know who doesn't want a
professional jackass around yeah by the
way that's me here just so you know
that's exactly how i got my job by
morgan stanley i was just going to say
that dude let me tell you you know
you you're talking of vince vaughn and
and vince asks two questions good friend
of mine good friend of the year
so you talk to him and you say so tell
me what are the three he asks you to
question exactly what are the three
things you say
well i was interviewing a lot of models
women about what they're looking for in
a man and comes along vince vaughn i'm
like hey vince you want to do an
interview yeah valuetainment ppd oh yeah
i know that what's up what's up so i say
well you know you're the famous wedding
crasher what advice do you have for men
well you know here's what i think and he
goes and and nobody does this and this
kind of goes to your point of being
curious and inquisitive he goes i don't
know but i see you asking all the women
what are your thoughts
i go thanks vince vaughn you know well
vince
vince's i know a little bit too and and
vince is it's also helpful that you're
six five and handsome yeah extremely
dangerous yeah he's a good looking guy
but he's also a guy who never was a
womanizer he never was he never he was
out to hang with his boys
he was driving a cutlass a cutlass at
the height of his
you know powers that guys wingers he was
never a womanizer no i i mean i know
from what i know
you know um he was never that guy who
was out i mean he could he could find
he'd find a girl in his in his glove
compartment they were hiding everything
yeah friends have done movies with them
and they're like dude it's crazy but he
never was uh he wasn't that guy he was
just he was more about hanging with his
guy
so boys so he asked him a question he
says so
he says hey vince you'd be surprised
what all the girls are saying is the
most biggest turn on for them he says
what's that humor he says yep getting
them to laugh he said we can get him so
with humor you can get into so many
crazy it's insane because
vinnie's like how do you think i get
laid out here yeah by the way i'm not
rich i'm not in movies but i just it's
just something where we're and it's
weird like i mean i've seen the hottest
hottest girls that are just like what's
some dude he's like he makes me laugh is
that it think about think about the
times the friendships you have and the
the things you hold on to the guys you
call you've known for 20 years what is
the connective tissue it's the times you
were laughing man
it's the times you were just you know
it's like that george carlin thing too
it's like they're they're the times you
feel the most alive and you almost
forget you're human one is inspiration
right it's like george carlin said don't
worry about the number of breaths you
take how many breaths how many how many
breaths are taken away how often are you
all happy that's right it's so true
because that would mean that's sort of
that moment of inspiration you hear an
amazing piece of music you see an
amazing movie you you you uh are are
having this moment with your friends
where you would rather be nowhere else
or it's a moment with a woman where you
like i i love this whatever those
moments are you forget you're human so
it's like laughter laughter is intimacy
man laughter if i'm not laughing or
learning get me out of there bro like
i'll see you later i got i got kids you
know yeah dude i'm we're so alive there
i mean it's it's you
when you you ever you ever been in a
you're shooting the [ __ ] with friends
you're at the house you're smoking
cigars you're at a bar wherever you are
and then all of a sudden you're looking
at your watch you're like
it's 2 30 in the morning exactly what
the hell just happened
great conversations great laughter it's
an unbelievable high and add food at
great that's it that's mandatory i'm
sorry forgive me for forgetting that
because without the food yeah yeah i'm
like because my cousin not to cook
yesterday i'm i'm playing on twitch call
of duty i stream with eric griffin right
so we're playing and my cousin's like
wait you're tomorrow with brian collins
he goes bro bro please tell him because
he had this moment with you and i was
there with him i forgot where you were
in l.a either breyer somewhere and i was
i was featuring her opening for you bro
he's he goes vinnie tell him that the
kevin spacey bit that he did he goes i
couldn't and i remember this because my
cousin's ball did he he turned beat red
he couldn't breathe and had to run out
of had to run out of the improv i just
shot that i just shot my special my
fourth specialist brandon
that moment
patrick it was the i i'm i'm not gonna
give it away because it's gonna come on
come to the show tonight so come on i
got two shows tonight what shows
tomorrow west palm uh improv it's a
drive but um
if you don't like laughing hard for an
hour and ten minutes
look you don't like laughing having a
good time for your features are killers
too and brian's one of one of the few
that i i as a comedian i don't sit in a
room and watch i just don't do it i
don't know i just can't it's weird when
people like sit sit in the front with us
i can't do it but this cat watching you
live it's it's like you're having fun
it's like just we're just in a room and
you're just
[ __ ] let me let me let me ask you
questions so all you all of you have
been
you were a comedian you tried in
colorado you stepped one to business
you're still comedian and you're
obviously still uh
performing as well so
what is the difference between today
because you've been in it
90s 2000 2010s now 2020s like i think
about a justin bieber right how the guy
found justin bieber usher's sister's
like oh look at this guy okay oh my god
this guy's kid's playing sydney you know
author it's pretty sick what if there
was no uber could would we have a justin
bieber that we have today i don't know
you see how uh
uh back in the days
the the what is the group don't stop
believing that's what is that journey
journey they find a filipino guy that
comes and becomes a lead so
has it when you see some guys like is
there a lot of stories of people that
just pop up and oh they're they chose to
become a comedian they got a big
following year and a half later their
comedians are getting specials is that
what's happening today or was that not
the way it was 20 30 years ago i i it's
a very good question you know when i
came up there was no social media
so you were always
thrown into a room and it was in boston
it was in new york it was in kansas it
was in la it was in bakersfield wherever
it was idaho is random now here was the
difference they were strangers who
didn't know you and oh by the way they
didn't share a common sense ability i
can do stand-up now in mumbai or bombay
and they're going to get the jokes that
they get in los angeles because the
internet has brought us together we
there is this sort of collective
consciousness this neural net if you
will that we all tap into
not so coming up so most of my career
most of bill burr's rogans all of the
older guys
were were we
came up in boston pittsburgh with a
bunch of working-class dudes going i
don't know you i work for a living make
me laugh and it got quiet quick if you
didn't bring the money if you didn't
bring the money and you were doing your
esoteric stuff that's so cool if you
were up in canada and then you came down
to miami i promise you it's a different
group and if you're up there doing your
stuff now
now what's happened is you can curate
your own audience
you have people that have been listening
to you on a podcast forever so you have
your fans are there and they're they're
it's like your family they're already
laughing because they just want to have
an experience with you
but the pressure is not the same so so
i think in many ways i'll take heat for
this but i think in many ways that's not
so good for comedy i agree with you 100
it's diluted because now i think i told
patrick earlier if you just make a tick
tock video and you have you know
millions of followers like you said
they'll come watch you they'll pay the
ticket you'll fill up a theater yes and
it's not it's deluded comic to me but
this is me don't i'm not and i hate when
people go oh you're hating or the hustle
i didn't i didn't say none of that [ __ ]
what i'm saying is
he came up before me but like you had to
go to these rooms and you had to feel
like it was word of mouth like you
became dope because you were talking
about you around the country you did
legacy media right you would go and do
the radio tour in the morning all of us
did no i don't care who you were yeah
and also nobody was making money you got
to remember that now comics are making
money so so let me ask you you didn't
make money back today
uh uh who is a like a real real og
comedian
even if you were to take out social
media so take out they have no file okay
so bill is one i can listen a bit all
day long sebastian madison
we had him on last year at the event he
was a freaking amazing dove davidoff
doesn't do comedy as much anymore but a
monster beast you know sam tripoli no he
doesn't you know people don't know what
a monster you can put sam tripoli up
anywhere anytime he'll do an hour and
then do a whole new hour and he can do
the most offensive [ __ ] or the or the
greatest stuff you're he just chooses
you know there are guys like that
up doing nothing but stand up oh sam
yeah but there's so many guys vinnie's
phenomenal have you seen i mean there
are a lot of guys who are just who who
can get up there and crush a room and
anywhere it is so i was if i had known
vinnie was here i know that i could take
vinnie and put him up anywhere in the
country thank you and he's going to he's
going to
he's going to take 30 minutes and crush
that room i can tell you he is because
he came up the right way
so you know
but but any of the old guys rogan you
know joe's joe was doing joe was see
people don't realize this either and
i've known justin i was 28 i'm 27.
joe was
crushing you've never seen anyone and
i'm gonna say you've never seen anyone
crush a room like he did when he was 28
29 30 31 32. he would get up anywhere i
don't care if it was mars
and that dude
he had he had a bit about two tigers
having sex
dude
i can't even it would it would bring the
house down it would bring the house down
he would melt it good luck following him
yeah good luck i don't care who i've saw
the biggest comics in the world try to
follow that it was like oh no no the
oxygen's gone guys the oxygen i watched
him in jacksonville he invited me i went
up there and jax won't listen to him i
felt like i had an ab workout at least
oh yeah i mean i was like and that's now
but back then he was just doing
now he's trying to say things now it's
like there's a through line there's a
theme back then it was just i'm gonna
i'm gonna that's all we should we would
get up and it was just all it was was i
want to see if i can this is when you
knew you were killing it if you could do
an hour and 15 minutes
and nobody got up to go to the bathroom
that's what these are crushed that for
me that was that's my that's still my
barometer like i'm looking i'm going if
i can keep these dudes if i can kill
these guys for that long without anybody
and then then you know you did your job
because when you're done they stay all
wrong no bathrooms that's when you're
doing it right let me ask you though
because i had mark normand here um on my
mark's great mark's great but now again
mark is a real comic and and mark was
not on social media mark is a guy who
came up doing five sets tonight in new
york city yes and that's my question is
because i even asked him because he's
been stefano he's been on rogan multiple
times mark norman right keller and i
said like would you want what rogan's
got i don't want all that drama i don't
want 100 million bucks i just want to do
comedy that's all i just want to be a
comedian yeah but we talked about
basically
you know the calendars of the world the
rogues of the world have been doing
comedy professionally for 20-plus years
pre-social media and basically kind of
like the tick talkers of the world
and i think this guy's funny trevor
wallace but like
you know basically tick tock instagram
influencers and ultimately my question
is is uh the barrier to entry the
barrier to entry was so freaking great
when you started you had to compete and
compete and be the best comedian in your
city in your city and you're sitting
now the bear to entry is you can edit
and do a video i don't care it that
never bothers me i love that people are
gonna make money now and stuff i never
worry about that stuff it's like for me
it's like boxing okay or fighting okay
you might hit mitts really well dude
that's great you might even jump around
a gym with a bunch of non-boxers and you
know okay
you go to a boxing the boxers who are in
it boxers or mma guys who spar and who
are at the top of the game who can
adjust hey that has to be earned you got
to do it wrong for a long time before
you do it right
they know it and everybody else around
them knows it you know it's like
whoever like that's why eddie hearn all
due respect to jake um paul i i respect
him i think this kid is actually i mean
you can you you can criticize him all
you want he and his brother
are
hard-working guys they work really hard
and hey they're putting themselves in
there you get in the ring and stuff now
now
jake i promise you in knows that's why
when he has these conversations with
eddie and he's like i got guys that'll
light you up well okay yeah because
those guys have been throwing the right
hand since they were seven yeah
you know so there are no shortcuts in
life there are no shortcuts in life
that's that's if i write a self-help
book please buy it it's gonna be
probably one page
it's gonna be one page it's gonna say it
takes forever
that's forever put in the world
copy brian and do it every day
yeah it's true though i mean it it's
true when you when you think about that
but today what what's uh again i don't
know if it's the same as it was before
did comedians have as much influence as
they do today 30 years ago because of
social media has a comedian now had more
influence than they did 30 years ago so
go back 30 years ago who was the face 30
years ago eddie who was the okay eddie
murphy george carla and george collins
my favorite crown me too and he
progressed yeah
richard but would you say they had the
same amount of influence if not more
than today or is today's top like like
take today chappelle yeah does chappelle
have more influence today than eddie
murphy in the 90s um i do think he does
because
but but again
entertainment uh has been so atomized
you know i mean social media is about
getting your attention there are so many
different avenues you're competing with
so many different ways to
and i i think that think about this for
a second like music let's just take
music music has become more of a
consumption it's become something that
you would digest you you listen to while
you're driving and then you're waiting
for the next tune it's so now you've got
dojo cat you got these different people
that have you know good for you knowing
don't know that
i don't know that
any musical group maybe kanye is an
exception i don't know but
like the influence or the impact
something like led zeppelin had
um or lenny bruce had or uh george
carlin had when
when the collective
mind was focused on four channels there
wasn't that much expression you had to
also earn
you had to earn so much of of
the experience you had to wait
for that right time turn the tv on you
couldn't miss it hurry up hurry up it's
starting you know it was that it was
happening there was no recording or
anything so when you watched it you got
to watch it once usually and it had such
an impact on you what's the what's the
tyler what is that art did we read that
article a couple months ago or maybe i
read this where it said as popular as
tucker is today
50 years ago there was a personality in
u.s that had you know 75 million
listeners on a daily basis because there
was only four channels did you did you
do that
i'll give you an example with myself
yeah in 2001 2000 i was doing a tv show
um i think it was 2000 2001 to whatever
it was and uh inside schwartz
when i was doing the goldbergs that was
a hit for abc was the biggest show nbc i
think maybe six million people would
listen and watch it that's that was
their number one i think
uh it was the goldbergs were just so so
that was yeah that was six million
people okay i did that show for almost
seven years then i did a spin-off with
my character when we probably got
five and a half six million people that
was a big deal that was a hit right
when i did in
2001 or two i did a show called inside
schwartz which was getting i think 15
million 15.5 million people to watch
maybe more we got cancelled because it
wasn't enough yeah right wow so back 15
million oh yeah dude because
friends and will and grace were getting
you know 25 30. so it that just wasn't
enough for the network they were like oh
no we got other shows so that's how we
were so we were so
focused on one thing
and that's the that's the biggest
challenge i think in many ways for us as
a society even think about how
christianity in the united states was
almost like
the focal point of our ethics our
morality our justice system the way
we're related to each other in god we
trust you said prayers in school that
was never controversial even though
there was this notion of separation of
church and state it was still a
christian nation quote unquote
try saying that now so so now we there
are just there's no fixed point of truth
i think there's no fixed point of uh
attention and that comes with great
things but also its own challenges so to
pat's question
that was a long way no i think i think
you're saying that basically
30 years ago the top comedian or the top
voice or whether it's the walter
cronkites of the world did have a bigger
voice i mean think about it
in the 90s how honored would you be to
go on johnny carson oh my god did you
ever go on it would change your whole
life yeah go i did letterman overnight
dude yeah if you're going jimmy kimmel
today does anyone give to you no no no
no it does nothing for yourself that's
the point yeah that's the point yeah i i
so i but i do think that having said
that
the world is also pretty polarized so it
might be atomized but it's also polar we
got teams man we got wokestan we got
trumpistan and then we got a lot of us
in the middle who are kind of like hey
dude i'm i'm not with this insane this
gender nazis i don't know what they're
talking about i just want to i believe
in the free market i like to own my guns
but i don't want spree shooters we you
know most of us are kind of like trying
to get life
and i think when you have a guy like
dave chappelle
who comes along and says
hey man i'm all for equality i'm a black
guy i get it
you guys are crazy
and then you get a you get a small
pocket of those people who are like
they're not interested in equality
they're just like how dare you and
everything else you know so it may seem
like he's but he has influence he's he's
who we're talking about why because he
took on the transgender thing right so
it's a tougher to compete today or them
because the way i see it is
uh it was a monopoly back then because
back then it had a lot to do with who
you knew like you had to kiss a lot of
ass to move up back then
today
it's so noisy to probably make it
today's gotta be
it's gotta be it's a different kind of a
heart i i guess the hard back then was
connection the heart today is
if you're not good
you ain't gonna last too long if you're
not good if you're good and you put in
the work eventually the market's gonna
you know pick you up yeah something's
gonna happen right
well there's that cult of the amateur
right what i like about today actually
though with social media is that you've
got a lot of comics from all over the
world man you got a lot of brown comics
you got killers coming out of the middle
east killers coming out of india killers
coming out of pakistan
my one of the guys is going to open for
me who's going to do a guest spot is
from pakistan killer and and that there
is a whole there is a whole artistic
movement coming out of that part of the
world and they don't have to speak they
can speak urdu they can speak hindu they
don't have to speak english and they
have a massive audience and they're
crushing it and then some of them are
you know their parents
went to england and they're coming in
and just taken over so it's competitive
bro you're competing with the world dude
big time but but growing up what you
said i don't think you have to be and
this is a fact you don't have to be
really good anymore because they're
still going to come watch you because of
the following you know i mean that's why
i was saying that it's been tainted
because they're not dude
off of what you said to get another one
of you or joe rogan or or one of these
big names
i i don't see unless they're gonna come
like diamond in the rough and because
they're just putting out a special
special his body uh uh uh
what's his name marcelo marcel hernandez
marcelo hernandez 20 what is he 23 24.
oh we saw him right yeah yeah he's got
money super
oh great yeah you know patrick listen a
lot of times we might be talking like
old guys
you know let me tell you something when
you get to a certain age you get over 40
what you start doing inevitably is we go
you know these young guys they just
don't come up the way we did it
they're not grounded
and i think that's been a phenomenon
since i had a history teacher who read
uh the lament of an older man about
these kids who are materialistic don't
know the meaning of hard work it was a
guy in ancient rome talking about the
youth of and it was such an eye-opener i
went yeah
dude i'm falling into this trap right so
i think to your point i'm glad you
brought it up is is
great artists people who are intelligent
who have an original way of looking at
things that hold your attention
they'll always be there and that's
what's one that's what's beautiful about
that the idea is the idea is you know
how you opened it up when you said
everybody thinks they're special but you
know we're just regular people and then
i said to you there's some people that
think they're really special right so
this this thing right here is yours
right nobody else has got this this is
yours this maybe you can change it
nowadays to look like whoever you want
to look like because sure you know
advancement is solid but this is you
right so a kid
who's coming up was like dude you have
no idea how bad i want the world to know
what
i'm special there's something different
about me and everybody else did that
energy if it's real
for that person and it's that important
the world is eventually somehow
somewhere gonna hear about who this guy
is or this gal is somehow some way the
next great one's around the corner we
have no clue who they are i just wonder
if the world you're because i'm
fascinated by calm my whole family
we grew up i was one of the biggest
pranksters in the army some of the
pranks i've pulled till today they
talked were you in the army i was in the
army man we were like not the pranks i
pulled
80 percent of them are inappropriate i
mean someone's gonna one day tell these
pranks that i did yeah i cancelled
things
at the highest level like if some of
this stuff was was just which is
terrible but back then it's just like
listen you're in the army you're doing
what you're doing because they did it to
you and now you're doing it back to sure
the new guys that are coming i grew up
in a family middle eastern armenian
assyrian sarcasm joke shots
if you couldn't handle being a bed david
or bohrosian you changed your last name
to something else that david was a very
very moral
yeah
i mean you couldn't it was a difficult
place to be and then and then that
continued in high school and then it
continued in the army where we had a
crew so guys were like hey can i go
party with you guys nashville i wouldn't
go to connections i want to go to mx
factory i was going like dude i'm
telling you i don't think you can hang
with us right and then they would come
in and say
oh my god you guys are ruthless yeah
that's kind of how just that's why you
grow up yeah i grew up in l.a i grew up
in glendale yeah grew up in glendale
went to glendale high school and then
you know went to the army and came back
but you speak fluent i speak fluent
armenian blue and a syrian
yeah i speak
i speak a few languages i break out the
old testament right now
so by the way you know the passion of
the christ when you're watching we
actually understand what they're saying
because we speak arabic yeah when we
hired as a dialect coach
come on this guy is better than me no
there's no way
like guys we don't have a race war going
on right here not just by the way we're
all friends here first out every year
exactly everybody just heard the first
language yeah but by the way why why are
you still in l.a are you like the last
of the mohicans are you like yeah
hoping for larry elder for something to
turn around i am dude i am i
i want the santas to come over now
i'm so done with this but i uh you know
what man i got my kids uh my ex and my
my children from my first marriage are
there so i can't you know i i can't
that's tough i can't got it there's no
way but if that wasn't the case i'd be
dominant okay so if that wasn't the case
me and shaw would have been like
shop too dude i we i looked at property
in nashville and austin i looked at it
but you know you looked at nashville
yeah
rogan still calls me everybody's like
get to austin i'm like i got kids i'm
not gonna you know you'll find him but i
tell you let me tell you my opinion my
opinion i don't want the austin
community to get upset at me i think
both austin and nashville is a pit stop
okay
and let me tell you why i'm going to
explain to you why this is purely coming
from my own case study because my pit
stop was dallas sure so i lived in
dallas for five years and i said listen
this is a great place no taxes they love
hard workers they love capitalism plano
people work the most hours per week so
they're workers yep they're not people
that want to leave at 459 community
they're you know they're willing to do
the job i'm three hours so i'm like this
is it babe we're going to stay here
how about the fifth year you're like you
know what i'm you know this we kind of
like this place called breakers and we
kind of like la and we kind of like what
texas offers and if texas and l.a had a
baby it'd be florida you know what why
don't we just move to florida so i think
nashville and austin i think is a pit
stop and i think it's about three to
five years until that pit stop is very
favorite my favorite audiences yeah
and in many ways my favorite place in
the world is miami really yeah
all i want to be at the end of the day
is cuban or at least are you married now
or no i i am i have a fiancee but
yeah
yeah
i'm actually
i'm shocked that you said your favorite
audiences are miami because they can't
pay attention to a freaking
favorite they want to worry about the
club and go partying and talking about
exactly he loves it you talk [ __ ] to
them what do you do
that that they have a secret look and by
the way yeah i mean if you want
cuban venezuela colombian
the women
like ask me what i do i dance
what do you do for a little you do i
dance
ask me where i'm from i'm going to be
romantic but well where are you from
just like yourself i'm from the
mountains my friend and
spain
lots of different places but spain it's
my heart
with my heart
so you're getting paid to just want to
be that guy i just want to say romantic
[ __ ] all the time so you gotta you gotta
play well you gotta play a movie where
you can do that one again i wish but but
so so la
you're probably going to be there for a
few years you don't see yourself leaving
anytime soon uh you know look i live i
live close to the beach i live in a
really cool part of la where are you at
manhattan beach okay yeah that's that's
right that's where our friend center's
at center's there yeah yeah that's not
really california though correct by the
way we just came back from la we were
there i mean at least when we went
together
the first time we were there in 2020
coveted lockdown it was a [ __ ] show and
we just went back and we were like and
mario was like let's go to venice and
see what's going on how shocked with you
how nice it was oh it's great
like we were personally telling homeless
people no they cleaned they cleaned it
up
when was this what did this happen
because during two days ago during
covert it was worse but now yeah i own a
house in venice yeah and uh it's i'm
holding on to it because it's what chur
what turned around in l.a because it's
better than it was because the sheriff's
department okay went down and they were
doing a live news conference and the
woman almost got knifed by somebody you
would see naked people these people are
the homeless situation the narrative
from the the left is that it's a housing
problem and it's an inequality problem
they are liars they're liars um it's
it's an ideology they hold on to and
they're not interested in solving the
problem sorry go to go to sacramento and
tell them uh that it's a
um
it's a mental health and drug addiction
problem is that what it is and it is and
when coveted hit those services kind of
evaporated for a lot of people
and that's why you had so many people on
the street um so the idea that it's a
housing problem and its inequality is is
not only a lie it's a malicious lie
because it doesn't do anything for those
people who really do need help they need
help a lot of these people are
schizophrenic they have serious mental
health problems that are beyond their
control
and i think it was adam carolla who said
if if there were a bunch of stray dogs
on the street in los angeles believe me
we'd do something 1 000 but these are
people so whatever uh you know and and
i'm sorry but if you look at the blue
estates they have the worst homeless
they have the worst they have the most
progressive tax policies they have the
worst homeless uh inequality problems
because they're not really willing to
take it on to go to san francisco and
tell me how that's working out because
with their d.a and and they're all those
all those essentially those marxists in
in power and they turn it around because
it's
california
who's running for mayor of l.a caruso
are you following that story or not yes
and i and it seems pretty cool well he's
he's he's made he's made the world worse
so could this tough on crime billionaire
be allah's next mayor
i think so it's tapping into fears of
crime los angeles frustration can you
make that a little bit bigger
homelessness billionaire real estate
developer has uh spent more than 23
million on his campaign to become la's
next tough on crime mayor and experts
say his record-breaking investment is
buying him a real chance at victory wow
interesting he's because people after a
while every society after a while looks
around and says this isn't working man
this is not working it it it's it just
doesn't you know we're the cause and
especially when you're paying that much
tax and what are you spending it on yeah
yeah i mean like you can help these
people and a lot of more vets yeah a lot
of those guys what do you think it's
gonna take for for you for california to
have a republican governor
well we had a republican governor the
the the issue isn't
republican governor i think the most of
the politics is all
local right so the larger question isn't
focusing on the gubernatorial race and
things like that
it's more about local politics we have a
democratic super majority i don't think
a democratic super majority i don't
think a super majority of republicans or
anything is good you need
you need pushback you you want there to
be this this argument these checks these
balances you want push back on both
sides that's how government churns
slowly and stays out of our business
there's an important distinction when
you talk about big government versus
small gun
big government is
not you you have to be careful of how
you define these things big government
go ahead it's really a question of when
that government gets
involved in your individual liberties in
your ability to make money use your own
risk your own ingenuity to make you know
a profit those kinds of things when when
when a government bureaucrat comes along
and regardless of the sciences you still
have to be in a mask and my children
still have to be in a mask i have a
problem with that you're actually
interfering in my child's well-being
because you have an ideology you know
whatever that might be i'm using that as
a hard example i know that's a
controversial issue but i think we have
to be very careful about how we draw
that distinction
in la what they need to worry about is i
think it's five women on the la city
council
who control a budget that's larger than
i think
all 40 other states right or in fact it
might be 40 states combined they have
they control a huge budget and it's five
of these women that i'm sorry or you
know i don't want the view
i want to i want a mix bro i want a mix
of people it's not about i'm not bashing
women it's about you know i just want a
mix of people i'd like hey you know who
i want controlling the budget people
that have to have made a business work
the other problem is that they don't
want to run though those guys like the
fact that caruso's running a lot of
times you know i said this the other day
i said you you know why is it that
people who would make great statesmen
that make great senators congressman
governors president have no desire to
run
and those who shouldn't are so motivated
to run i know because because it's two
different personality types i think that
uh there's the person that's the
you know hall monitor and then there's
the person doing it look it's the whole
monitor guys running think about it for
a second we need economists fantastic we
need think tank people we need but but
when you're an economist you're not
paying a price for being wrong when
you're an entrepreneur you pay a price
for being wrong you adjusted the price
of pain this is what you know i think it
was uh the book uh
the hell it's called uh not black swan
but the other book um
uh skin in the game uh well well well
kind of great book great book because
and it's so true i think you're going to
learn more about how the economy
actually works from an entrepreneur i'm
not saying economists like paul krugman
etc don't have their
place
but
they can say whatever they want and they
can push uh um sort of an idea i i their
hands aren't that dirty i'd like to see
some calluses on your hands you know
what i'm saying so so if so if our
politicians let's just say newsome is a
hall pass guy
what's trump
if newsom is asking for the hall pass
who would trump be uh trump is the
wrecking ball and
trump's just the giant orange guy who
comes in and goes
chess and he just throws it
and he's like
let's rock and roll you know trump is my
my buddy caddied for clinton
trump
obama
and bush
and caddy is he you learned a lot of
caddying like that so this is a lot of
insider five hours where where was this
was from canada my buddy cameron booth
yeah in florida yeah
caddied for jordan he was on the tour
great guy
and a hell of a golfer and uh he's he's
not he's he's not a political guy but he
said he said the best golfers trump
and the one guy you'd want to have a
beer with at the end of the day is trump
like like you say what you will about
him i i think the problem with trump is
that he's just such a narcissist he just
he's such a trumpist and i mean he just
loves himself so much and he greats on
people he's probably a bit of a con man
i'm sorry but you got to admit the man's
funny the man cracks me up and he's and
he does have some good ideas when it
comes to the economy 100 i mean so so so
i think where we fall off the mark is
when we go he's a you know in la you
can't even have this conversation now if
you even if i even say
trump's yeah i don't like trump but if i
if i even have a small caveat that there
are some things
you get attacked performing in la you
can't say things like i
do you really feel it though
trust me you feel it i i did something
where i was like i felt bad for because
i know i go where my trump supporters at
that was a i opened with that so the
energy was already it went to [ __ ] yeah
i was like come on there's and then it
was almost like like they were scared
like two or three i go i go don't be
scared of these [ __ ] i go where are
you it was such an awkward and then i
got off stage and the met the gm and
somebody was like hey
you shouldn't i don't think you should
you should take that out of your i go
what a joke that i wanted you you could
say the n word and get away with it
faster than you could say well trump but
i'm not joking in california
100
but
we
go deeper on that obviously they don't
like trump okay but why is it is you
just can't bring it up i think it's part
of the insulation culture there what's
the deal i think trump is a really very
ice a very polarizing figure i think the
way he speaks and and uh
i
i i think he was he's definitely not
very presidential right
i think that
what the
democrats and the left made a mistake
about
is that they didn't realize that most
americans are not voting for trump
because they're racist misogynist and
all that other stuff they're voting for
a guy because after eight years with a
democratic president etc they had they
still only had 500 in the bank
and
that's what matters to most americans i
want to be able to send my kid to
baseball after school i want my daughter
to be able to take ballet lessons i
don't want to have to make a decision
between milk and ballet and if you don't
understand that that's the case with
most americans then you aren't around
most americans and for me
you know what i notice again is that and
i'm not saying the left doesn't have
ideas i'm not saying that that a lot of
people on the left or people who tend to
be democrats don't have aren't good
people don't have good ideas aren't part
of the mix aren't necessary for certain
things in society we need each other
i notice that the people that are that
are making a lot of the decisions the
people that come from a very expensive
uni
fam a very privileged background a
family that's well connected with a lot
of money step into a very expensive
school with very expensive walls that
you can't get into
and then they go directly into a
newsroom back into academia
or right into politics or into hollywood
what does that mean
they haven't come into contact with
objective reality enough they just
haven't and i promise you i promise you
that most of them have never had a
plumber a landscaper
someone in the military or anybody that
works with their hands at their dinner
table
they are not it's not because they don't
want those people there they just don't
come into contact with them the people
of color they talk about the people that
actually need help i promise you they
don't know
and
again i'm not saying it's their fault
i'm just saying it's what happens we get
very segregated and we are
you know you you fall into a class
substructure and you stay there man you
do
and they have compassion they probably
have guilt they want to make a
difference in the world and they start
studying inequality and they start
seeing these things and you have an echo
chamber in these academic institutions
and nobody is pushing back there are no
conservative thinkers there just aren't
there are no
uh there are no real capitalists because
that's not who gets into academia look
at look at the difference between what
happened with jon stewart and bill maher
you go back five years ago who's who's
god between the two that's a great
that's like john stewart that's a great
look with john so john
still wants to be invited to the same
parties with obama still wants to be
invited to the same parties with you
know hollywood whatever it is and bill
maher's like no
no this is who i am and listen if you're
like me because i talk [ __ ] to everybody
on both sides and this is what my comedy
is and
look how much bill maher has changed
he's going well he's just speaking
science we all agree it's true but but
what you're talking about is very hard
to do for a lot of people you know it's
very hard to do because it's like oh my
gosh but what if this happens and what
if that happens no sometimes you got to
sit there and say you know i i don't
know if i agree like okay so kellyanne
conway is on the view i don't know if
you saw that or not she's on the view
and they started booing her and then
whoopi's trying to play the role of hey
you know we're equal all this stuff hey
i don't care if you agree let her finish
her thought and then she says you know
uh uh uh something about trump he says i
told the trump and trump response to
this it's hilarious he says while the
first uh team trump debunked okay former
president donald trump on thursday
morning personally lashed out at
kellyanne conway over her new memoir
here's a deal in which she recalled
telling the ex-president that he
definitely lost the 2020 election while
the first term president trump
uh rebuking on conway in her book this
week via spokesperson the latest lashing
was posted on trump himself in the truth
social platform he says kellyanne conway
never told me that she thought we lost
the election
if she had i wouldn't have dealt with
her any longer she would have been wrong
could go back to her crazy husband okay
like yeah the problem with trump is the
minute you the minute you push back the
minute you push back he's like i don't
like you yeah
his loyalty lasts as long as you you you
consider him god she is so listen so so
this was his most trusted advisor even
she will go under that button
let me put it to you this way let me put
it through this
to me kellyanne conway is tucker from
milwaukee bucks when they traded him to
miami okay you you know what i'm saying
you need certain you know what you're
dirty so
your team was fearless yeah she was if
she by the way if if he loses her if he
loses her i'm telling you right now it's
going to hurt his chances
if he loses kellyanne conway you can't
lose kellyanne a good point that you
cannot lose kelly uncommon it's like
it's got guts yeah you there's
you you cannot lose
kellyanne conway but at the same time
man you look at trump to respond away
do you like trump are you worried that
he's going to split the ticket if i have
to choose between santas and trump oh no
desantis is not running against trump i
know that because i know that okay the
sentence is not run the sentence was in
our community last tuesday they did a
fundraiser last tuesday in bay colony
desantis is not running against trump
now okay i could be wrong last minute
things can change because a part of me
we talk about it when we say you know
i think
sometimes you think momentum is going to
be on your side all the time and i don't
know if he's ever going to peak like the
way the santas is peaking today right
because
you peak when there's crisis and he's
peaking yep so it's nine years
that's the story that's the challenge if
he runs against trump it's a tough one
it's a tough one because trump's going
to play dirty and you have to go dirty
as well yourself and that's just going
to happen so it's not going to be a
trump desantis ticket you see a lot of
guys here putting trump to santa's
ticket i think that is as unlikely as
a kobe and jordan being on the same team
it just doesn't make any team it's like
putting two big personalities on the
same team try to run together that's
going to be tough you need somebody to
be pippin you need somebody to be the
second you know person neither one of
them are guys like that so
if it's against biden
if it's biden being on the ticket
because right now what the left is
struggling with is who they gonna
replace biden with
what's their story going to be
how they're going to present it to the
audience the only way you can do it the
right way is you have to
come up with a health
story in the next 12 months it's
probably what's going to happen the next
12 months biden's going to come out and
going to say i went and had a test with
the doctor and the doctor's telling me i
have a cyst or have something and
unfortunately we're trying to do our
best and if you hear stories like that
that is the
uh narrative which is kind of like the
narrative of soft landing and saying oh
my gosh you know you know he was
president while he was dealing with
cancer what a what a vulnerable man so
then we're the uh america is gonna get
emotional and sentimental look he was
doing his best while he was dealing with
cancer some story like that maybe it's
cancer replace cancer or whatever else
you want to replace it with but they
have to find a candidate it ain't kamala
nobody likes come on
not the left not the right not the
middle nobody likes kamala and let me
just say this too before i want to hear
you face this because i was saying that
a lot of people on the left don't come
into contact with objective reality it's
the same thing with the right there are
a lot of people on the right now who
like you know who don't the people that
are making decisions tend to be they're
looked at by americans as being very
wealthy and out of touch as well right
so
but keep going i want to hear you yes so
who do you have so think about what's
left after that so then you got to go to
peat buddhist which is who they want to
market okay
it's going to be very tough because of
foreign policy oh you'd be amazed how
many people behind closed doors
a first husband i'm being serious yeah i
agree like it's it's a it's like
america's
where we've come a long way but let me
tell you something brian callan i think
we are ready for a gay president yeah i
just don't think we're ready to see him
kissing his husband on tv for america
yeah again
gay president i'm okay with that yeah
walking down the the the russians are
going to be like that's interesting oh
this is your guess it's really
interesting and then pat going up well
some say we've already had a gay
president but that's a difference yeah
there's a whole difference you were
saying so
and here's the thing brian come on
patrick the rumors people like us that
are like listen trump with the
policy-wise you can't deny it okay and
what pisses me off again with my
democratic cousins that are you know
pretty liberal pretty kind of leaning
left this two years you guys have had a
chance to show us you know what the hell
would trump you know policies decides
whatever look how good we're doing look
at what's happened in these two years
now because of your guys's side's
policies you're giving him the easiest
way right back in so i don't want to
hear the [ __ ] talking when he doesn't
win but i don't i'm not i don't worry
about democrats and i don't worry about
republicans traditionally democrats and
republicans are
no problem you got both sides of the
aisle that that's it makes government
move slowly that's that's how the
country was founded i got no problem
some people tend to lean more democrat
more republicans maybe it's a
personality type do you see what he just
put up how you put a smile on my face go
back to the picture while he's talking
you put a picture like then you expect
me to keep a straight face this guy's so
funny look what he does
how am i supposed to keep it straight no
way that is hilarious is that a real
picture no i think that's cropped but
that is not a real picture
but it's funny is it a real picture no
it's not i was going to say that okay
it's not it's not that he's gay it's
that he takes three months off from
eternity but certainly and he's uh and
we had a supply chain crisis by the way
because matt zeller believes it needs to
be two years
no way
but man
we'd love to have you back home
that the the leave needs to be two years
but who's gonna pay for it exactly
you're gonna pay for it i'm gonna pay
for it so go back to the you don't have
problem with the democrats
my issue is this far left woke agenda
that has taken hold they are
when you start talking about when the
new york times runs
81 articles i think on gender neutral
bathrooms
when the world's on fire and this was
back when i think it was a couple years
ago it's like you're so out of touch
with how americans think you're so out
of touch when trans rights are trumping
everything else dude you're talking
about a very tiny tiny minority of
people
that when when you want to take children
and put them on puberty blockers because
you're an expert in in gender dysphoria
i don't
know you're not no you're not and i
don't agree let a child's brain develop
they they go through phases you know
these are common sense things and when
the left hijacks when they start doing
that the far left starts doing that and
they drown out the reasonable voices
what happens is it it creates a whole
bunch of people on this side who go you
want to go to war dude you want to go to
war we can do this that's what i worry
about i worry that i really worry when i
hear
people over there talking about tearing
down institutions
and
characterizing the united states as only
a patriarchy a tyranny
a racist country
all those things okay we're a lot more
than that we are a lot more just like a
human being is sinners saints and
everything in between bipolar apes and
so is a country we're a work in pride
progress we're a work in progress this
was called the grand experiment for a
reason it's still going on the
constitution is a verb the united states
is a verb it's an idea that continues to
evolve okay but i think the founding
fathers solve the political problem okay
a little a little credit where it's due
the words you use like feminism
individualism universalism humanism all
those words were invented by the people
you're criticizing and by a system
you're criticizing the first amendment
which you enjoy very much and saying
what you want and screaming was fought
for it was fought for with blood and it
had to be fought for as an idea and it
had to be won as an idea all those
things that we benefit from every day
you may be a socialist i respect you but
you're also tweeting from your iphone so
a little respect for the marketplace as
well if you could right let's be let's
be aware of where we came from let's be
aware of the kind of foundation that was
laid for us before we got here that we
benefit from every single day because
whether you know it or not your anchor
is in that bedrock and thank god for it
because the founding fathers as far as
i'm concerned solve the political
problem you know who didn't the greeks
and everybody else so
they're james madison alexander hamilton
you're talking about john jay you're
talking about
genius the federalist papers is one of
the or the greatest idea in philosophy
i'm sorry it is and why do i say that
because we still live in the greatest
country in the world because everybody
has a chance we still have potential i
need music when i'm talking
a monologue it's like i become an actor
i get tired of my own voice i was
waiting for somebody to stop right the
american flag behind you were waving i
love that by the way the speech whatever
that what whatever that uh that was
amazing am i wrong not at all my
question is what's your biggest issue
with society today because it seems like
you've got a bone to pick up
polarization
i i'm afraid i worry
that that nobody can even agree on where
the truth is coming from we never had
that problem that's new for me
and what i mean by that is back in the
day i could go i heard it on a news bro
and we go well the news is vetted i
trust the new yorkers oh what did you
hear it on cnn or fox my dad my dad
always said the new york times was
always lean left but you still trust it
as a source of information there's no
question the new york times was a
trusted source of information so was the
wall street journal even though it had a
much bigger role for the audience that
doesn't know what did your dad do for a
living
my dad was uh i i grew up all over the
world
you know what i mean i grew up all over
the world wasn't it like a cia hey whoa
hey hey
we're talking about here you keep you
keep waking up free every morning do
what he does ray leota just passed away
that's a little respect my dad was a
banker yeah worked at citibank and we
lived in i was born in the philippines i
lived in uh
calcutta and then bombay and then
lebanon then pakistan the lebanon
lebanon again then greece
what do you do for them why do you leave
three months at a time baby this is a
big deal big private equity deal we all
saw true lies with arnold schwarzenegger
buddy man a man can't can't do work
during war so your dad said even though
new york times is left it's vetted so
you can trust yeah yeah and i and i
think to
and i think now when i when i say
something like no i heard it on tucker
carlson or i heard it on cnn
i lose half the room
because they go they're liars and i
think that's a problem right the the
biggest
maybe
challenge that we face is that when you
can no longer agree on one source of
truth
you are going to have people that not
only
align themselves with their own echo
chamber and are aligned themselves with
the kind of truth that that fits their
narrative right that confirmation bias
but you have an entire mechanism of
information that allows you to get
pushed even further in that direction or
even further in this direction right and
now you've got two you you have almost
this this cyber civil war that could
happen you get these parallel economies
and people have talked about this way
more eloquently than i have
but
it kind of harkens back to
the
phenomenon that allowed europe to have a
40-year civil war world war one and
world war ii
was
maybe you could make the argument an
offshoot of the fact that
truth itself became
atomized i mean let me give you an
example it used to be there was no
question about
what time was and along comes einstein
and says time is relative
what oh by the way time might bend
and uh and and light bends and oh i can
predict the movement of the planets you
don't need the bible for that bro let me
explain something here and and haley
came along and said yeah haley's comment
all of a sudden we go whoa whoa wait a
minute that's kind of nutty and then you
have a guy named um freud who comes
along and says hey there's you're
unconscious and there's conscious
there's also something called the
subconscious and oh by the way you want
to have sex with your mother
there you go
there you go europe
deal that you want to have sex with your
mother oh and and by the way you're
ruthless about your sexual selection and
then another guy comes along named
darwin and says hey um there's something
called evolution there's design without
a designer god doesn't exist don't need
him uh
there's also something called
sexual selection and it's ruthless maybe
women actually like the guy with the
strongest jaw the broadest shoulders and
the most aggression
and all of a sudden we go hold on but
the meek shall inherit the earth that's
cool dude yeah you go adopt a
three-legged dog i'm getting this i'm
getting a four-legged dog with a strong
bite and i want i want good guns and
that and and and that's why when
nietzsche said god is dead
what he meant was
god may be dead but human beings are
religious anyway and we're going to come
up with our own religions and our
religions are going to be communism
fascism capitalism we're going to come
up with our own religions and the
problem with that is that now you've got
ideologies and when you have ideologies
you have camps and then you have
charismatic people that have control of
the guns that take over like stalin like
hitler right who say um this is the new
truth and oh by the way i'm going to
reshape society as the utopia i envision
we can make human beings perfect we can
make society perfect so you might be
flawed now but kiss my ass i'm going to
make all you perfect and the only ones
who are a lot there are some people by
the way who we can't educate you guys
you guys a little older you gotta go
you gotta go
you got i can't hey it's just business i
gotta purify i gotta break a couple eggs
to make an omelette this is what
happened and so
if you think that can't happen today
i would only say that
i promise you
stalin's russia and hitler's germany
said the exact same thing before they
came to power
you know it's like it could never happen
here yeah they said the same thing
i mean that's a pretty bleak thing again
i need music so you're very i need music
you're very optimistic about the future
i i actually am yeah i think you are i
am in your own dark way you're
optimistic that good things are around
the corner well because human beings
figure the way through men yeah i'm just
talking a lot but people are like their
people are aware of the things i'm
saying
are you like you're not are you are you
more depressed now that i brought that
up no no you're like no not at all pat
says all the time the future looks
future looks bright so there's no one
that's going to tell me why tell me why
you're give me get me out of my uh why i
think the future looks bright yeah oh
one million percent future looks pride
because exactly what you went back to
uh
you know you know how you said the hall
pass guys and and the guys that
uh uh the bully who bullied until he
finally realized that you
uh got the one kid you bullied to spend
uh 10 000 hours learning how to fight
and then he came back and he not only
whooped your ass but you knew you could
no longer cross so what what bullies
don't realize they do is
they they create a michael jordan they
create a
dave chappelle they create a joe rogan
they create a
uh
they create
they create any of those of course no
question i mean
bullying comes in different forms
bullying is not just about being a kid
bullying is you know
somebody with money that you know their
money came from family and maybe they're
imposing themselves on you a little bit
and you're sitting there saying dude i
would whoop your ass and i'm gonna out
work your ass you're okay no problem
let's see what's gonna happen here and
then you go out there and prove your
point exactly but i think i think the
the right people are waking up today
kiyosaki and i had a zoo we're having a
conversation we're working on something
together
and uh you know he says hey i think we
need to have this kind of podcast
together me and you this guy was i was
in the marines with him back in the days
and you know i screwed up i got kicked
out but he didn't he stayed in he became
a lieutenant general and later on became
a congressman and we both think that we
need to raise men more today etcetera
said i said
he said so how do you feel about today
with everything that's going on because
you know market crash is coming and it's
going to be very ugly uglier than what
people think is that true oh dude i'll
clear them what people think is that
right
wow if you go if you
if you have the ability you're gonna buy
a lot of stocks so cheap right now did
you see plan what palantir ceo was
talking about did you see what happened
to the palantir stock have you seen that
or no tyler did you see what happened to
the valentine stock so first of all
that's a good stock to own it's going to
go lower okay snapchat did you see what
it dropped to in september it was an 83
dollar stock snapshot it's a 13 stock
damn what 80 drop okay so you got every
one of these stocks you look at where
they're at right now all of them but
it's gonna get worse the next 12 to 18
months maybe 24 months to market house
prices are going to drop 20 to 40
percent when uh in the next 12 to 24
months house price is going to drop the
next 20 20 12 to 24 months
so what do we do it's gonna happen the
people what do i do it's the people the
people that are prepared are gonna go
and add
they're gonna take their net worth and
do five to fifty times in the next two
to five years five to fifty times you're
gonna see guys and i'm telling you right
now you're gonna see
million dollar guys be hundred million
dollar guys the next two to five years
you're gonna see 10 million auto guys be
billionaires the next two to five years
the ones who are ready yeah but you're
also gonna see the highly rep leveraged
200 million dollar guy become a 17
million dollar guy damn you're going to
see the highly leveraged 18 million
dollar guy become a six hundred thousand
dollar guy damn the next uh again my
opinion this is coming from me purely as
an opinion you can trash it you can
break it apart do whatever you're doing
however i thought you're gonna be
brilliant
this is the part
the part that's bright unfortunately
every once in a while pruning is needed
every once in a while just like the
forest has got a lot of trees yeah
itself creates fire to
take you know and then next thing you
know the ones at the bottom that are
really the ones that are going to be the
stronger powerful trees they're the ones
that needed the sun they're going to
come up and be uh better and beyond like
even right now you look at sports every
time play like look at luca lucas larry
bird but except five times better you
look a lot of these guys that are coming
up in every sport and every business and
every game podcast comedy in every way
someone's gonna come and do it better
because what they have
is tens of thousands of hours of people
that did it before them they're just
going to make it better yeah okay so but
opportunity oh there's no question about
podcasting like we all everybody's like
oh yeah these liberals look what look it
created an entire economy the daily wire
wouldn't exist at all you know
podcasting like people are making a
fortune
pushing back with either a
reasonableness or a right wing
when one door closes another one
by the way you know who wholeheartedly
agrees with you
uh maybe just the uh founder ceo type
guy of tesla and now twitter elon musk
you know what he i don't know if he
founded uh tesla but what did he have to
say about this he said exactly what
you're saying tyler you have that
article what was your business patrick
insurance until today i'm at the lauren
insurance company we have twenty
thousand agents nationwide
we have 150 office i'll put an event
together in august wow uh in las vegas
we'll have 15 000 people there sebastian
was the performer last year at my annual
convention
and he came up he was freaking
hilarious amazing mario lopez was our mc
you know we had that article
but yeah
you're a guy i listen to because you're
in insurance
you're risk you're about risk purely all
so so i'm listening to you very quickly
of course that's something i don't care
about elon musk i care about a guy who's
actually doing it no but i'm saying elon
musk kind of knows a thing or two about
the economy well patrick what would you
say i know you guys want to get what
would you say to somebody that isn't the
millionaire it doesn't have a hundred
but it doesn't have 20 million let's say
a family that has let's say 20 30 000
saved what would you tell that family to
do right now
i love that great question but check
this out like like what have we valued
the last two years
how do you know
who is legit the last five years how how
the hell do you know we you know how
they say we have an economic expansion
of 128 months no we haven't we
we've had an economic expansion of
nearly 150 months 140 months take cove
it out if you took covet out and they
kept rates at zero or half a points
federal reserve this economic expansion
would have continued past february of
2020 right so what happens when the
econom economy is growing how do you
know who's a real millionaire mm-hmm
like how do you because so many people
are leveraged yeah how do you know you
don't know how do you know who's the
real comedian how do you know who's the
real there's a filtering process that we
all got to go through right that's right
okay
so the only way you know the filtering
process is during bad seasons that is
the only way you're gonna know who's
real and who's not the foundations are
stronger so so the last two years
everybody's like dude forget about just
go get your own job go to the other
companies these guys don't want to pay
you guys will pay 30 grand ask them for
raise if they don't leave them tell them
to work from home tell them to a work
room or tell them give them a threat
they'll have to give it to you they'll
have to keep you give all that stuff and
you know what's happened the last two
years
employers who've been bullied are
sitting there and saying
damn
never in my life have i valued loyalty
and actually keeping your word when you
say you're gonna do something number one
more than before wow so companies are
gonna take care of those guys because
the last two years all the people that
abuse companies are getting filtered out
wow and it's gonna be so freaking
awesome ugly so ugly here's another one
if you leverage too much money and you
know you shouldn't have and you were
banking on the market continuously going
up there's this thing called risk you
may have a good hit and good for you you
may make 5 10 15 20 million dollars
but if you overly leverage with the
whole thing we're talking margin call if
you overly one aggressive there's a lot
of billionaires today who were
one quarter away from being poor and
broke there's a lot of billionaires
today yeah there's a lot of billionaires
who
the market went their side they sold at
the right time they bought at the right
time they lev all the leverage at the
time you price stocks i i i've been
since 21 years old i was a stock broker
i was at valleys i was a stock broker
but you know so so today next two years
you're asking that person if you're the
person that's not the person with money
dude uh wherever you are build the
reputation of somebody that's gonna come
through
show value show loyalty show expertise
increase your skill set the market is
gonna see through the [ __ ] the next
two years i swear to god
the next two years everyone's gonna know
dude this guy's not worth 50. we got to
pay this guy 80.
you know what this advisor is not worth
the commission we're paying he deserves
more money than what he's doing with my
money because he was honest with me it
kind of come down to what we were
talking about like coming into contact
with objective reality yes right like
like that's like you other it's what i
love about fighting comedy and that it's
really true comedy and fighting you
can't fake them you either make people
laugh or you don't when you're in a ring
and i'm watching a guy it doesn't matter
who your publicist is who your agent is
or what they say about you you either
got the goods or you're getting knocked
out and i
life business it's a scary it's that way
right oh it's a scary it's a ski it's
again it's a scary side but it's a great
filtering site yeah and and if you're
you're good with it
you're fine
if you're prepared you're fine if you're
not
you're not but this this this next two
years two three years this two to five
year run that i'm talking about uh uh
for for you and i
we may never have another two to five
year like this i don't think its
conditions are going to be as great as
it is right now to create wealth the
next two to five years and by the way i
i'm not selling by real estate i'm not
selling buy insurance i'm not selling
anything all i'm saying is the next two
to five years there's going to be a lot
of things for sale and everyone's all of
a sudden gonna come up the filtering
system you're gonna say dude i had no
clue that that was real i had no idea
that guy was real you know the whole
thing when you said you know like uh uh
if i had a book to write a self help
book could be one page and the page will
be what it takes for it it takes forever
well guess what you know this
we're looking around and we're wondering
oh that guy's probably a legit guy or
that guy's probably legit guy it's gonna
take about 20 years but it's gonna take
about 20 years for us to realize who the
real legit people are in every field in
every field in every field and the next
two to five years we're going to learn
who actually and manage your money and
who did it it'll create opportunity too
and fortunes are made in recessions
right all the time that's what i'm
saying please text me and brian like buy
this all the time
i love that i really i appreciate that
that's that's very interesting this is
the quote from us let me know if you
agree he says it's actually a good thing
that this recession that you're talking
about is going to happen it says it's a
good thing
he says it's been raining money on fools
for too long and some bankruptcies need
to happen i said century i so agree with
him
i so agree with them the whole too big
to fail you know how sometimes the left
says well how about the too big to fail
i agree yeah yeah
we can't [ __ ] bail them out let them
let go
let them go a little bit let the pruning
process come let some of these guys that
are not good operators get fired
remember what shamath said about the
airport remember when when tooth when
the kobe just hit they started bailing
out all the airlines tell those guys
yeah and everyone's like what do you
mean let them fail yeah what do you mean
that's not that that's the marketplace
because everyone did their stock
buybacks right before uh after the um
trump uh
tax cut
and all these guys who were had an
influx of cash all these major
corporations airlines what have you what
they all do they bought back stock right
did you see the credit and then they
were just not uh with solid did you see
the bitcoin thing falling and all this
oh it's it's 29 by the way go back to
this one a bitcoin margin call if the
world's leading cryptocurrency drops
below 21 000 michael saylor's micro
strategy will be forced to pay up what
does that mean okay so uh he he bought
170 000 bitcoins i believe 125 170 000
bitcoins
so uh michael sanders
sailor and mit grad and the co-founder
ceo the business intelligence for
microsoft azure become faithful yes ever
since company began stockpiling the
cryptocurrency in august of 2020 the ceo
has gone for uh as uh to call bitcoin
freedom as the most universally
desirable property in space and time and
in 2022 miami the largest bitcoin event
worldwide sailor was met by thousands of
cheering fans as he instructed the crowd
to never sell their crypto
and look at the dollar amount right
there
3.97 billion dollars he bought 129 000
bitcoins
do you see that can you highlight that
129 by the way
he's not wrong about bitcoin
so it's not like he's wrong about
the the technology no he's not wrong
about that this guy's a
this guy's
made and lost a few times in his career
i think back in the 90s he was worth
nine billion dollars and he went back to
a billion and back up to seven billion
in back then so yeah he's he you know
you know
you know michael burris
you ever watched you ever watched a
movie big short big weird i read the
book good book okay so you know the guy
christian bell christian bill that's
that's a real life michael burleigh okay
yeah michael burry and this guy have
very similar ways of he was the guy who
saw the saw yes yeah he was the
mathematician but michael bury right now
have you seen what michael brewery said
last week did you see what michael
brewery said last night you got to pull
out what michael bury said last week
michael bury is calling it it's it's uh
uh uh
okay yeah that one right there two days
ago can you click on it make it look big
short investor michael berry compares
the stock market slump to a plane crash
and hints troubling stocks
and home sales remind him of the housing
bubble bursting great i'm listening to
that guy well let me tell you something
right yeah you know how long he's been
saying this every freaking year since
2008.
kiyosaki
i don't know if he's been saying it's
every year since 2008 no no some of
these guys no this is how they make
their name very talk [ __ ] no this is
don't don't do that because this is not
that guy michael bury's not that guy
michael berry remember the one time joe
got upset at stephen a smith because he
was giving feedback to ufc and he's like
dude what are you doing don't do that
again and he says i will never do that
again because the guy is not from this
world this is not basketball this is not
football right joe knows the world joe
gives criticism joe has the right you
better listen to when joe says it right
because this is his world yeah michael
bury
is not a guy
but
try inviting michael berry pay him 200
grand to speak at your events see what
it's gonna be a disaster no no no he
won't take your money because he's not
that guy yeah invite him to a podcast
he'll say no he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about the eyeballs right this isn't that
wiring of a guy this is the genius he's
got that tourette's thing or that uh
that that ass
yeah he's one of those guys so when he
says that he has not been saying this
since then this is a guy that said this
in oh seven oh six came right and then
everything's leveled off and now he's
saying it back again but he's been
saying it adam for the last two years
that's what i'm saying but not since oh
wait there's a big difference yeah this
oh he said it in a way for the last few
years he's been saying yeah that's
there's a gap of 10 years that he didn't
say it it is i'm not going back
so
much in the quantitative
easing
yeah just think about it this way okay
uh uh somebody does steroids
and you go out there and do
a bunch of stuff and you see a guy like
[ __ ] what happened to this guy this
guy's 160. he's at 205.
i've never seen you look like this and
then you got friends that are gradually
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger but it takes like a year two
years three years five years okay cool
but the guy that suddenly who's not
working out and comes in and adds
everything and it goes to 205 from 160.
yeah you're sitting there saying dude
the moment you can no longer 40 grand a
month or 2 grand a month or you have to
get off the cycle and then your body
shrinks up and you get to the yellow
skin and you look very awkward and weird
and then now you have to get back on it
or try to filter it out of your body for
six months to 12 months
america is about to go through that
phase my dad used to always call it the
difference between style and substance
it's just you know substances is the
difference you can you can dress
yourself up and look great you can act
like you're rich you can spend a lot of
money on a ferrari you can you can work
it out and have a great house but
how much money you have in the bank you
know it's the same thing and how good is
this business really are you providing a
product people actually really want to
use is it making the world better well
how's your nft collection working out
for you this this stuff never made sense
to
me
i still don't know what it means i i
never i never understood did you get any
of that stuff or do you have an nf no
you don't have like uh but i bought one
bitcoin just to see what was going on
some ethereum just you know i was like
let me see what happens did you hold on
to it yeah but i never i never your
board ate yacht club nft ain't working
out look at it
by the way you know you're talking about
the whole metaverse thing did you see
the story that just came out pretty
crazy story about meadowverse check this
out so women 21 years old is virtually
raped
by a stranger
in metaverse app yeah may 26th yesterday
right yeah and you read the story of
what uh uh direction we're going to so a
page three uh let me read this full
article to you
okay a woman was virtually read by
stranger meta horizon worlds metaverse
app while another user watched and
passed around a bottle of vodka
new reports claims about an hour into
using the platform the avatar was
sexually assaulted during a
disorientating and confusing experience
the researchers said it happened so fast
i kind of was dissoci disassociated one
part of my brain was like what the hell
is going on the other part was is in the
uh this isn't a real body and another
part was like this is important research
horizon worlds was released by meta in
december and allows users to gather with
others play games and build their own
virtual worlds you know this sounds
weird to us let's just say right because
i'm 43 and you know okay i'm
seeing this happening but
this is very real where we're going of
course this is the direction we're going
right so it's gonna be the scariest part
about this
is if this becomes a crime
i'll just say this because if this
becomes a crime yeah then the way to be
able to manipulate
crime later on i mean this just opens it
up a little bit too much yeah like is
there going to be like a now now that
this has happened
do they go like to court and like does
this matter
i don't think you can do that but what i
think is interesting is that
i had somebody say this this is not my
idea so i don't want to steal but
they said anybody who's buying property
on the metaverse is kind of a fool
because
you just you can't put a value on an
infinite supply of something
the metaverse you know yeah
yeah there's an infinite supply there's
an influence
all it takes is another algorithm you
know so guys are selling a guy sent me a
message yesterday saying i got a special
land for you for sale if you want i want
i'll make i'll let you uh make the first
offer my number is 2.4 million i said
yeah i'm good bro you know i wish you
all the best he said about the metaverse
yeah he's trying to sell me land for 2.4
million a big nfc guy says i'll sell it
to you for 2.4 million this is going to
be 5 million dollar property i'm like
i'm good totally fine it's gambling yeah
there might be people i mean
i mean people who have made real money
off nfl and and
that but that's all because
it's just like crypto that's all because
even though there isn't much of a like
if you if you have bitcoin if you want
to buy a child or a or a
a lot of drugs or a nuclear weapon i
suppose bitcoin would work but for the
most part there's still not really no uh
there's not a real economy that is
girding this or undergirding whatever
the word is but i do think that isn't
isn't and i'm i don't know but it isn't
bitcoin and all these cryptocurrencies
they are
valued because a lot of people are
buying them just in case
but by the way what he just said has led
to a
uh research i don't know if you saw the
article on how crypto bitcoin is
matching with what the stock market does
meaning the pattern
is now whatever the market does 79 out
of 93 days if the stock went up
bitcoin went up if the stock market went
down bitcoin went down did you see that
the
that article that was texted to you did
you see that article or no kai send it
to us i don't know if you got it or not
it's a very very i thought bitcoin and
crypto was supposed to be an
uncorrelated asset i thought it wasn't
supposed to be tied did you read the
startup no i haven't okay so it shows
uh kai if you're listening i don't know
if he's listening or not if he can text
it to us but it matches exactly with
what the stock market did
uh uh that article right there bitcoin
is acting like the stock market and
that's not that's not it that's 2018.
hey kai do you know the article you send
me about how bitcoin and stock market
are correlating can you text it to me
uh i just send them a text right now
through audio but it shows so that right
there is not a good sign by the way
that's not good because if it's
mainstream yeah then then it's not good
so then
but the part of it that the bitcoin
community can say it's good is what well
guess what legitimate no no no yeah
we're not only legitimate bring some of
the bigger money because it's like it's
the same thing as stock market bring
that in but then you lose your identity
of being you know we're we're own you
know we're we're own libertarian we're
getting our own goes back to what you
were saying though it goes back to
the fact that okay you're saying this is
valued at x okay
but
where is the exchange of goods and
services
you know the the dollar i can understand
even though we have quantitative easing
and stuff but for the most part you and
i decide that though the market decides
the value yes and by the way i'm not a
i'm not a big i have bitcoin and have
ethereum but i'm not a guy that's going
around telling everybody go buy bitcoin
but all i'm saying is the market will
determine what's what's what's crazy the
last couple years is
that gold is
gold is no longer what it was because
like right now
what is the price of gold a kilo of gold
right now tyler if you type in a price
of of gold
kilo what is it right now 57 000 it's a
guess 59 0005 okay
my price is 61 000 okay so
if it if it went based on what the
market was doing yeah
it should be a hundred thousand dollars
it should be 80 000
right but the patterns of how gold
reacts to what happens to the market is
not happening that 1554 peter schiff has
been saying that's going to be 5 000 for
20 years
it's eventually going to get to 5 000.
so he's eventually going to say i told
you i was right but 20 years too late of
saying i was right right
so there's certain things that's
confusing i think the next two years
you almost need the next two years to
see what moves what doesn't so
everyone's gonna know if bitcoin goes
one direction
and then you know interest rates go up
bitcoin goes up but stock market goes
down that's when the bitcoin community
right there look at that bitcoin has
been trading with the stock market this
year okay
uh uh what's the day that he has did he
just texted you
what's the number of days look at u.s
dollars dude look at that look how close
it is wow look how close that that means
people are being careful isn't it isn't
that because people don't have as much
confidence and they want they want to
link it to something that's been proven
to be
real for a long time you mean with
bitcoin or the stock market bitcoin
they're calling a digital gold right now
okay go go to that article that's what i
want to read okay can you make it a
little bigger bitcoin has often been
linked to a digital version of gold
which for years has been safe haven
asset known as a
tr uh thrusty
trusty store value when times have been
more uncertain but evidence for bitcoin
fulfilling a similar role is hard to
find in this year at least indeed the
data of 2022 suggests the price of
bitcoin often moves in the same
direction as stocks rather than the
opposite of the 98 trading days we've
had so far
bitcoin and s p 500 index have moved in
the same direction 73 of them wow that
that wow so i want to know what the
bitcoin community says to that while
moving in the opposite direction only 25
times the biggest moves in the stocks
like the u.s stocks fell 3.2 percent on
my knight also came the largest moves of
bitcoin for the stats nerds the
correlation between the two has been
plus 0.53 interesting so how are you
processing that how should it be moving
differently it's so you're not unique
you are the stock market you're not
unique you don't so versus what i would
have wanted to see is
if the market goes down the next 6 12
months and they raise interest rates i'd
like to see
if i'm if i'm a pro bitcoin guy i would
want to see bitcoin go up
i'd want it to go up to sixty thousand
seventy thousand eighty thousand ninety
thousand if it does they have the
argument the same way as if gold goes up
the next 12 to 18 months because gold is
the armageddon sale right the world's
coming to an end you better own some
gold you know
brian you gotta put them putters out
five percent of portfolio go buy some
gold and set aside but if it doesn't go
that way then the gold audience that
selling gold their argument is kind of
their own investors are going to be like
hey john you told me the last eight
years if the interest rates go up gold's
gonna go to five thousand it's still at
fifteen fifty what the hell is going on
well you know what's different about
this time they lose the argument well
let me ask you this yeah
personality types who makes more money
do you think usually pessimists are
optimists
does the pessimist start with money
do either start with money or that's a
good question but because because i had
a meeting with the founder of with the
son of moody you know the moody's family
ever heard of moody's moodies movies
they're all over the place in texas and
i had a meeting with the guy and i went
and pitched him an opportunity 11 years
ago i said here's what i think we can do
we can make billions
and i was done with my presentation he
says patrick there's two types of people
in the world
there are those that wake up every
morning
wanting to make their first billion and
there are those that wake up every
morning wanting to protect their
billions your group one i'm grouped too
[Laughter]
that's great so
so in a way you have to be an optimist
to make two million
you have to be your best friend when you
already made it that's a great so it
depends that's probably why you become
conservative when you have that much
money and you're and you're wild man
when you're young yeah when you get
older you're like
think about why like think about
conservatives conservatives are there to
preserve what we have and liberals are
there to be like let's let's let's start
something new bro progressives
you should be a money manager you'd be
one hell of a money man you crack up
your clients he said look you know what
i wasn't going to give you the other 20
million but here's the you know i trust
you you're going to make no money but
i'll make you laugh
people too emotional
by the way are you following the amber
hurt story are you following my favorite
tv really it's my favorite okay so so
so so far yeah with all the craziness
you saw by the way uh what's her name uh
uh camille uh vasquez yeah has
officially become a bm bmf people are in
love with this girl 38 year old lawyer
what i want to know is how the hell did
he find her like what did that show up
that was apparently a very deliberate
choice because they said that the two
lawyers are the big guys they're guys
your size apparently and if you had a
big man
asking these these very hard questions
to a beautiful woman who's crying you
would look like a bully
let's get a very smart small
so sarcastic no i'm being serious what a
strategic
the team when you're johnny depp and you
get that team
i promise you they're the best yeah i
know some of these people you know that
in hollywood who deal with this they're
the guys that make it to the top those
lawyers they they are deep deep students
of hum of of human nature so here's my
question
how did dude not everybody's defamation
i know it's them but do they have to
agree and like it's going to be
televised and it's going to be on every
single day like what what makes that
look this this case rests on on the
first half of that the sentence the
first sentence of that of that article
yeah i was i was i became the face of
domestic violence the idea was you wrote
that and then you orchestrated
um your follow-up plan to essentially
destroy someone's career and the case
really is the lawyer's case is
we're gonna prove that everything you
said is not true
right you're making this stuff up we
don't have there's no pattern of this in
his in his history or anything else all
of a sudden you came along said that i
mean if you listen to those tapes
it's like she's saying i'm i can't help
but i get so mad i can't promise i won't
hit you
yeah i wasn't hitting you johnny i don't
know what my hand i didn't punch you i
was hitting all that big difference so
all of us just go i'm sorry but mo
there's people like why is that why does
the internet hate amber heard well
most of us the people don't have a dog
in this race like are like i dude i just
don't buy it i don't believe you i don't
believe you the letter that you're
referring to she wrote that she was the
face of domestic violence
she wrote an article for the washington
post or the
that that basically said um if you look
at the first sentence i think it was
really about whether or not she was
did this was a defamation thing i spoke
up against sexual violence face faced
our culture's wrath that that has to
change and then i was exposed to abused
at a very young age blah blah blah blah
there's there's a sentence that they're
using that that
now you have to prove whether or not
everything she's saying is a lie
let me ask you a question then oh yeah
there it is two years ago i became a
public figure representing domestic
abuse and i felt the full force of our i
became a public figure representing
domestic abuse that's where i believe
it's hinging on you said that you were
abused and then you filed a restraining
order and i i will say this if you re if
you file a restraining order in los
angeles you don't need to go down there
personally with your with your um
uh publicist you don't if you file for
divorce you don't have to go down there
personally you don't do that a lawyer
does that for you a clerk does that for
you
so why was she down there you know
without makeup on that cheek there was
and also if you heard the tmz guy he
goes well
we have to vet who has the copyright for
any video we get
and that'll take up to a day or a week
in this case it took 15 minutes because
it came from quote unquote the source
that was her well it came directly from
her i saw i mean that's what i mean come
on
if it took 15 minutes yeah tmz was like
oh well brian and if you were supposed
to believe all women well yeah except
for uh just lane maxwell
the woman from theranos i was just gonna
say
how are you processing this believe all
women how are your categories i have a
big problem with any of that so any
blanket statement that this can i say
one thing though look at what americans
love this type of like this trial
where's jelaine maxwell what happened to
that whole i would rather see that trial
than watch this i hate to be that guy
where's she at now where when the last
time you heard of elaine maxwell yeah no
no i know where she is she the depp was
the one
who wanted the cameras in the courtroom
oh really
she didn't and he knew these this is
by the way look man that guy's a
nightmare too okay i i don't think he
was i don't think he hit her it didn't
but that guy spent 30 years high
high and drunk off his hat
nightmare he was jack sparrow in real
life dressed like a pirate all the time
look if i came in bro with a lace doily
around my head a cowboy hat and 15
bandanas you'd go brian
i take it off right now
come on buddy he's an artist i know bro
but you gotta have friends who are like
hey dude you're you're dressed like
you're 13 bracelets but that's what
johnny depp is you're 60. just because
he's captain jack sparrow drinking rum
on a pirate ship he's a man doesn't mean
that he's beaten women in acting class i
took it for years in acting you learn
the most important thing which is what
learn how to be still yeah
learn to give nothing away yeah let the
audience i never learned this by the way
not even close to the worst student let
the audience reach for you brando brown
was the first guy who just steve mumbles
words
back then you always had to enunciate
you learned how to stand straight and
you and you spoke this way you were an
actor that was very important yeah
brandon came along when he walked on
stage in in
in london
he came on stage
and he was talking like you stanley
kowalski when he was doing street car
names there
in london they thought a drunk stagehand
had walked on stage
they they were like
what's going on oh my god somebody's
storming the stage and they realized he
was in it they saw his muscles and they
saw he was actually sweating for real
because he used to work out the first
method actor
in london
they were cheered the story goes they
were screaming the women were screaming
at when at that curtain called screaming
he changed all of it robert de niro
robert duvall all those guys you know
who their hero was brandon brand of
course brando so you know the the
depp is a master actor dude he seduced
all of us by barely moving it takes him
a half hour to get one sentence out one
one sentence he's like i
it was
no
what that's all he says we're like dude
i need to hear more yeah
is it true you had a you had a pint of
wine yeah
a mega bind a mega pipe i had a large
glass of wine i felt very necessary but
who's your favorite uh you continue you
guys like this
yes you continue to read that correctly
he barely raises his voice how much was
he spending on wine he even admitted it
30 grand a month
that's as much as patrick david does
good who's your uh your accents are
amazing you do great accents okay who
are your favorite people to do these
days
i mean i've always if i really want to
do you know that's a hacky thing but
yeah i've always loved
chris walken
and i'll do christopher walken as a
pigeon for you i'm only going to do it
once okay this is this is one of my
favorite guys by the way yeah
well that the story goes this is a true
story that he he walked in to my
i think it was i can't remember that
randy pearlstein who was a comic and he
told tells the story he's telling on
stage so i'm stealing it from him and he
said
walken walked up to them when i don't
know if it's true but he was he was
drunk and he walked up to them they're
all hanging out and they're all just a
bunch of actors who were in this movie
called search and destroy
and he walks in
and uh they're all like oh [ __ ] chris
we're walking and he goes and he's tall
he bet you that's 6 3 6 4 and he goes
you guys
you know
what fame is
fame is knowing you could walk into a
room
[ __ ] anyone
in the ass
that's fame
and he walked away
and they're like
what
what happened and then he's dancing with
an actress like this he's doing this and
apparently he'll look over his shoulder
and go the ass
i hope that story is true but it was a
great
story it's true yes yeah you want to see
my impression of christopher walken as a
pigeon
go this is [ __ ] so cocky
i should have my comedy license revoked
this is bull i apologize i'm defaming
it's chris walken as a pigeon
cool
[Laughter]
bread
i got bread on my mind
sourdough
cool
thank you very much everybody thank you
very much very impressive very impressed
come on dude that's how that's
high-level action i i just discredited
myself
by bitcoin guys that's the point i'm
trying to make oh my god by the way uh
when you when you were in hangover it
was a bad i know people are going to be
like shitty walking [ __ ] off i wasn't
even trying yeah it was a great walk-in
but did you guys party out on when you
went hangover was it just kind of like
work was it purely work all work nobody
knew that movie was going to be a big
deal you're joking bradley i'd known
bradley and zach galifianakis and all
those guys nobody knew the movie was
going to be no
i'd known bradley cooper for five years
before that i knew zach alphonax for 10
years before that it was a little movie
uh you know i was asked to come in and
you know uh i knew todd phillips the
director and the guy was supposed to be
from new york talking like this you know
you don't remember me i'm eddie you know
how could you not remember you know
he was all yeah he's from the bronx in
new york and i was the one that i said
look dude if the dude and i even said
this because you'll appreciate this i
said if he's in vegas and he owns a
wedding chapel he should be from armenia
or lebanon or something like that you
know he's i can get you anything you
want my friend
it's a bit different divorce
divorce guns i can get you chicks
whatever you need my friend i can get
you wine
he he loved that and that was how it
happened but when we did the movie bro
it was like
you know
i mean i tell the story you know it's
it's so funny because
bradley and i were walking through i
think caesar's palace and a group of
tourists
wanted to take a picture with the guy
from mad tv
what do you want to know who held the
camera and took the picture right now
wow blue eyes nobody knew him why it
wasn't he was sack lodge and wedding
christmas i remember when limitless was
the movie they were watching and see if
you could pull it off and he did that
was a great movie that was a sick movie
but that guy nzt yeah but he was all he
loves acting bradley i j i just saw
because of ray liotta you mentioned it i
watched goodfellas last night probably
i'm not joking for the 50th time and
while i was in the gym today there's a
documentary where with scorsese and the
writing with nick pillaging yeah
everything and then uh henry hill he uh
the real henry hill he wasn't witness
protection he couldn't come on the set
but he would uh rob de niro would call
him in the morning five six times and go
hey how did this guy hold the cigarette
how they talked how did he pour the
ketchup how did he well i get goosebumps
right now and then god rest his soul do
die that ever since i was a kid i wanted
to be a gangster you got your favorite
movies oh good fellas has got to be one
of them man on fire is oh
uh
godfather two
john q have you talked to all these guys
huh sammy the bull sami i was pretty
fascinated with him he's the only
gangster that i
was really
taken with because he i knew who he was
back in the day because i was in new
york then and he was terrifying you know
but
he just seems like a very intelligent
guy who had if it wasn't for his
dyslexia would probably be a huge
entrepreneur would probably be a guy who
made a fortune like i i know it's crazy
to say this but i get the feeling
that even though he was a killer he
lived by that code of the samurai he's i
i look at him as more of a samurai you
know people who kill people are
you know gangsters are bad people right
they just i don't like it there's
something about that guy i feel like he
was just more of a modern day miyamoto
like a like a samurai who lived by the
sword and was always ready to die by the
sword
that's my feeling i may be wrong i don't
know what was your impression i mean
sammy is
till today he is still to the core proud
mafioso and he'll he'll tell you when we
spend those three days in the mountains
and we did the mafia states of america
with him and uh uh michael franzis you
spent three days with him oh yeah we we
had we in the mountains in the mountains
with
we did with uh rudy giuliani and we had
chance parliamentary do the do the
narration wow how is it so fast security
wise what's the signal we have to have
security
bananas nice they both ask to bring
their own people and is that true
they're each the people that they
brought on each side you know it's like
they're they're people people they
brought their own people so you do you
have to because i'm asking them to come
to the top of a mountain at a house that
matches identical to the house from
godfather too helicopter comes down
[Music]
yeah there you are look at this house
oh yeah they went at it but they were
with each other it was a great uh are
you nervous about that that was
no because i've already done a lot of
stuff with both of them i had first time
i talked i called sammy it was uh a year
and a half after the michael frenzie's
interview so i call sammy he gets out of
jail one of my the girls jessica gets
his number and i called him i said hey
sammy this is patrick with david who the
[ __ ] is this so patrick david i
conducted the interview with michael
francis so you the mother so you did the
interview you realized michael wasn't a
boss he was a couple and i'm an
underball and he got all technical
so he went two hours furious about the
interview and i said sami just meet with
me he says no
i said sammy let's just have a meeting
i'd like to interview he says no the
only person that's ever interviewed me
is diane sawyer 1994 got 20 million
views i'm not doing any more interviews
wow so i said why don't i just come fly
it says no hangs up
i said okay i'm going to follow up
because i'm a sales guy so i'm going to
follow up i love it i followed up
followed up
and finally who's this sammy it's
patrick why are you calling again and
then anyway so we talked finally
you know he agreed to meet in in phoenix
so i fly into phoenix and he says i'll
give an address last minute when you
guys get here so we get an address we go
to this place
and a guy comes to the front he says
here let me take you to the back we're
walking walking walking walking walking
place gets dark or walking
it's me and mario mari says pat
is today the last day i'm living i said
nobody just relax you're never gonna
leave this place so we get to the place
we sit down and then sammy shows up and
he starts talking
and he shakes your hands oh yeah yeah he
starts asking questions but the entire
time he's just watching
your body language what you're doing
what you're saying asking questions
asking mario questions why do you want
to do this what's the outcome of this
how am i going to know this this is not
going to be a hit job what is it going
to do is this anyways very very very
short no he's done so many sit downs in
his life that's smart guys they kind of
sit downs that your life depends on it
right
anyways six months after that he agreed
we did the interview
and uh it it did very well and then this
the scariest person though that we met
with wasn't sammy it's two other guys
frank colada was one and sunny francie's
sonny francis was michael's dead he was
like if you ask sammy about sunny
frenzies he's a level of religion
because if you sonny is the one that was
the rumor had it that he used to be with
jackie kennedy and marilyn all the
stories that people say about jackie and
marilyn monroe it was a sunny story
that's who sunny was i mean it was a
massive article down us
sonny that something years in jail
so we go to new york to meet sonny at
the old folks homes after he got out of
jail okay we go to the hospital to see
him
and i go in there with mario
sunday looks at me like this he's
looking like 10 second pause he's still
looking at me not moving just like this
imagine somebody looks at you like this
and then he looks at mario like this for
10 seconds
he says you rat
to mario you rather know he says you
know 95 percent of the world they're
rats you rat
and mario like doesn't know what to say
he's looking at me
he's looking at me like i'm like
sonny he's totally fine he's a good guy
he's been with me for 15 years so you're
not a rat
no okay good well good good having you
here let's go and then we sat down and i
was trying to do the interview with him
toughest sale look how he is
uh by the way he died a year ago year
and a half ago and that's michael and
his dad where is he right in the middle
there
but in the picture he's the one in the
middle right there look at that face
right there okay some of the stories
about him
it's a myth i can't even tell the story
some of the stories they say about what
he did anyway so we go back part two i
got my whole camera crew there
everybody's there we're about to do the
interview
i'm taking him to the top italian
restaurant to see if he's going to be
comfortable we're driving to the
restaurant
and i said so sonny you know
uh what do you think about marielansky
because he comes from that era
good man a very good man i said really
was he a billionaire no
just a regular man but he was a good man
so what do you think about uh
lucky
oh
phenomenal man very good man
i said to stories about what lucky did
never very good man yeah that's it i
said how about you'll get you're like
that's what you'll get i said how about
bugsy you'd never call him bugsy to his
face
to you his ben siegel very good man fine
gentlemen yeah so i go how about frank
you know so i'm going through all these
stories nothing i said sonny
let's do the interview because if you
don't do the interview the world's going
to tell your story how about you do the
interview with me
and let you in control the narrative you
tell the story let the audience make the
sales pitch and he's looking at me like
thinking about it and his lawyer sitting
to his left
it was the most uncomfortable lunch
because a lawyer screaming shouting you
know it's very ugly at this point it's
like 15 people at this table we've shut
down the italian restaurant it's just us
michael's sitting to my left his lawyers
there our people are here everyone's
waiting for sonny to say yes
and then all of a sudden he's like
yeah listen
here's all i have
all i have that i'm taking to my death
but with me
is i've never ratted anybody out and i'm
not going to talk
to anybody
that's why he did 55 years yeah he could
only though
do you ever see a movie called angels
with dirty faces with james cagney
it's a great movie because it's about
it's about one guy who gets caught
they're two juvenile delinquents one guy
gets caught the other guy gets away from
the cops the guy who gets away from the
cops becomes a priest the guy who gets
caught gets stuck in the system becomes
a gangster that was the guy from made it
ma top of the world right so he becomes
a gangster and the greatest thing about
that movie is this
they finally catch him he's going he's
going to the chair he's going to get
electrocuted and the priest his old
friend who couldn't who ran faster his
old friend came to comes to james and me
and james cagney's in the jail cell and
he's like i'll die like a man i'm not
afraid of these these people you know
i'm i die like i die like i live i'm a
man
and and uh the priest comes to him and
says i want you to do me a favor and he
says what and he says i want you to go
to the chair like a coward
and james candy goes what and he goes i
don't want you to go to the chair like a
brave man because these kids on the
street will look up to you
and i don't want them to look up to you
wow i want you to go to the chair like a
coward and he goes all i got all i got
is this that's all i got and you want to
take that away from me in the last
moment of my life you want me to be a go
to the the chair yellow which was a
coward like a coward and he goes i do
and he goes i'm not doing it get out of
here
that's all i got and the priest leaves
with his head hung low
and then you see
james cagney being walked to the chair
and it's done with shadows on the wall
gangs and he's walking i got this i got
it i got this and he's walking like a
man and like damn he didn't do it and
then just when he's gonna go he goes i
can't do it no tell me please
i don't want to die and they have to
drag him to the chair and then you see
the kids reading and it says you know
what's his name goes to the chair like a
coward and the priest is just watching
these kids going man i always looked up
to him and he went there like a coward i
don't know is this really worth it man
that's the how you how it ends
it's called angels
come on boys let's go have a drink for
the for a kid who couldn't run as fast
it's a great movie man but james cagney
at his best there i mean how about that
what a freaking story how about that
dude i mean that that's that's the but
that's what the opposite of what sunny
did
sunny went and sonny went and said no
this is who i am yeah to the core by the
way you know the number with sunny is
55. you know sammy's got 19. sunday's
number was 55. bodies kills people oh my
goodness that's the number that you're
52 or 55. they can it's somewhere around
the 50s
102 103 and a half
that's why you can ask him about lucky
and meyer and those guys because a
hundred and four years ago it was 1918.
imagine that so you know
so i think there might be something to
the fact that you know people are born
gangsters sometimes people like sunny uh
like uh sammy the bull they're born what
would we do without our bad guys
movies and life would be pretty boring
what would cops do without our bad
about their guys that way that story
that sonny told us sitting at the table
on the podcast
about the guy
i'm sorry that that that samuel told us
yeah was that not the most intense story
one of the most intense stories oh you
mean the story about the the guy who was
a hitman's hit man yeah he can't take
his shoes off yeah exactly take my shoes
because my wife will not oh my god that
was the most intense story i've ever
seen in my life bro dude that's where
you just go and but
sammy the ball garano might be the best
storyteller i've ever seen and i'm in
the business of telling stories yes you
want to talk about a storyteller and the
thing about it is i believe every single
word that guy says that's the other
thing that i really appreciate i'm
pretty good at reading [ __ ] that's
my you know i'm an actor would you want
to interview him yeah would you want to
have him on the podcast i would i'll be
okay i would love all right guys
okay i'll make
the introduction really
how do you get not to cut you off by my
bad how do you get sammy the bulls
number how does that happen
hey do you better not don't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
question excuse me mr bet david i want
to apologize for my friend
he's a little out of line funny i wasn't
funny
funny how
let me tell you let me tell you a real
funny story and then we'll wrap up this
has been a blast but so we go to a local
restaurant here who's uh called the casa
de angelo if you haven't been we gotta
take you okay you're gonna lie i told
joe i said joe they got the best veal
not veal best elk you got to go to this
place to try to elk he says when i'm out
there we'll figure it out but uh so i'm
out to florida we moved to fort
lauderdale from boca we moved to fort
lauderdale
and first week i'm going to casa de
angela this is known as
people would go to this place to eat the
owner's name is angela it's purely all
italian employees 80 italian all of them
like from in italy
so first time i go eat there i go there
with uh chad's momentary
so the manager comes out the owner comes
out oh okay who's this guy we go to the
corner we sit there okay
second time i go there a week after that
yeah it's with michael francis look oh
michael francis hey you know him so okay
we go there third time i go there is
with sammy this is three weeks in a row
i'm going there so it's chas you
remember this right because we're going
together with all three of us there all
three so we go chaz we go michael we go
by the way chaz is dinner what's one of
the best dinners of all time yeah
amazing i love that guy so the third one
we go is with sammy
by the fourth one it was the week that i
was on rogan i was on his podcast so on
the podcast i give a shout out to the
restaurant casa d'angelo
by the fifth time we went back there
these guys are thinking i'm italian and
they're thinking i'm like you know from
italy
i said you're you're a syrian that's an
original italian what do you think where
do you think the romans get it
from armenia and assyria yeah
i tell you what though man the the the
story obviously you're you're you know
fascinated by the story
and it never gets old because there's
more stories yeah you know when sammy's
telling the stories or michael's telling
the story frank colada when we
interviewed him i'm in vegas
and we're staying at the mgm mario is
setting up the place if you can pull up
frank colorado so he knows who frank
colada is
so do you remember seeing so we walk in
frank walks in and mari says oh frank
we ready we have everybody ready here to
to do the interview you know i'll i'll
text it to you so you know who it is
frank's like yeah don't worry i've been
sitting out there for 30 minutes who was
the guy that came and dropped off the
camera and the lights and all that stuff
tell me who that guy is because that's
what i've been watching whoa holy [ __ ]
so mario's like oh oh uh that that's
that's one of us you sure he's one of
you that's him frank colada okay trust
anybody bro oh let me tell you so
he walks in if you've never seen the
interview
he walks in
zero like hey
zero hitch cold as ice
when the interview ends
i'm talking to mario on this side to
check to see if we're gonna grab one of
the lights or to leave we will we look
around he disappeared
gone gone he disappeared no no hi buy
nothing he's gone he disappeared he
messaged me a year after that he says
hey i had no idea our sit down was going
to get these many millions of views he
says my business is taking off in vegas
let's do something
a couple weeks later he dies he just
died now if you don't understand his
business if you don't know who you are
don't ask jewelry
he came from chicago i apologize he's in
the garbage can what's wrong with you by
the way frank colada frank colada if you
want to know who he is
you ever seen the movie uh uh casino
yeah of course you know who tony
spelatra is
okay tony spelatra is like the sammy of
vegas let's just say like that guy like
a phil leonetti of vegas
right yeah so okay
so tony spell that's right yeah bad bad
guy but in the movie if you've seen
casino remember when they go to the
scene where they put the head in the
vice and they the guy that blows up the
guy in the head and device that's colada
that's his move he did that oh wow
that's crazy that's frank very bad guy
very bad qualifiers guys are a real
associate yeah it's like they don't care
about he is cold like you yeah
the way that you tell stories the
accents the things that you you're gonna
have a great time with sammy if you can
set that up yeah the guy can tell
stories and if he didn't oh i know end
up in that life he could have been an
entertainer comedian it's that i've
zapped
you know set it up for a couple hours
you know you know set it up for a couple
hours
he makes his own time i'm not going
anywhere
yeah you'll have him on the fighter and
the kid oh i'd love it yeah how can you
do that twice a week twice and it's just
you and brenda me just me and brennan
okay guys so that would be sick the
team's back that'd be sick i don't want
to bring up any weird stuff but i do
watch it all the time and brendan was
just on with bobby lee yeah
is that something you're talking about
these days i'm i'm i love that guy okay
i've been friends about before ever i
yeah i spoke to him in a way that was
inappropriate i was mad about something
i was given information should have
waited on more information i should have
given him the benefit out because he
didn't know what the hell was going on
and i and i called him up and i i own my
mistakes dude i love that about you
because you're like this is on me it is
this is i don't know anything to see
what happened we patrick has no clue
about this well i'll tell you i'll fair
but yeah but but it's fine but but um i
love that guy yeah and and i've known
him forever and i call him and i go i
apolo he was mad he read me the riot act
and i was like you're right when you're
right you're right but when you screw up
and and you you
you get angry and you don't give you're
a friend of yours like that the benefit
of the doubt you deserve a little heat
and and but i respect you bro brian it
takes a lot which i love you for this to
because nobody does this [ __ ] nobody i
own my mistake
i did it because guess what i've been
angry angry and in that moment yeah bad
information whatever right i've done
[ __ ] to where if it was the other way i
would have punched me and i was given
information that that was i should have
waited and i should have and i said when
you have a friend who when you have
somebody who i like as much as bobby
yeah who didn't deserve you got to be
able to say you got to ask him you got
to go hey you know explain to me and and
i and i was outside of myself wasn't who
i am made a mistake you're human yeah he
accepted my apology i i apologize we're
good man it's all it's great but you
know what's the big lesson you learned
through all this whether it's bobby or
ricky or who doesn't what's the lesson
you learn don't assume
give your friends the benefit of the
doubt and you know make sure you got all
your information in your ducks in a row
and even when you do
ask for something first don't you know
go and say what's going on
it's not like me it was uh there were a
lot of extenuating factors i was given a
lot of information i was defending a
friend
you know brendan's like brennan's my
brother man so so i i i'm very
protective of my friends i'm very loyal
but i should have realized i was also
talking to a friend somebody i love very
much i've known bobby for how many years
25 years great longer than brenda but
he's also he's also a great dude yeah
bobby's hilarious too yeah well you guys
did mad tv together well we were on i
wasn't on the same thing but i've known
him forever and i've always had nothing
but great love and effect and his girl
kalila she sees i don't know her i don't
know you don't even know her at all i
don't know her bobby seems very
level-headed though oh yeah i don't look
i don't have any beef with that that's
not that's something that uh was
unfortunate it was one phone call
and uh and i apologize right away yeah i
respect that you own that yeah you gotta
own your you were very clear this is on
me yes ma'am that's a you gotta own you
gotta
you're freaking awesome and we had a
great time with you looking forward to
so you said tonight you're performing
palm beach and tomorrow west palm beach
i got two shows tonight two shows on
saturday one show on sunday i don't take
the lord's day off dude
can't stop won't stop you understand
what's going on committed you are to
your faith i respect that a lot
so
what an amazing comedy jesus
go to palm beach
and then sunday he's doing one for the
lord so again brian thanks for coming
out there guys have a great weekend
everybody bye bye bye bye
you